- What up blog, hope
everyone's doing super well.
This is a keynote that I gave in Singapore
that really struck.
There's a bunch of stuff
in management and running
operations, a lot of my stuff
is for early entrepreneurs.
I think for everybody
who is running a business
with several employees or
seven figures in revenue
are gonna get a lot out of this one.
So, I hope you enjoy it,
and I hope you like my sweater.
♪ We're unstoppable ♪
- I'm really excited to be
here, thank you so much.
So, we have a lot of time
together, which is amazing,
and so, I will take
full advantage of that,
and to be very honest, I wanna
get into the Q and A part
and start throwing this out
to you guys to ask questions,
so I'm gonna try to get to
that as quickly as possible,
because I think, for me, when I speak,
and what I think has
allowed me to have a nice
speaking career is I'm
obsessed with bringing in
as much value to the audience as possible.
My origin story of Belarus
and lemonade stands
and baseball cards is
something that you can see
on YouTube over and over and over again,
and as I continue through
my career of speaking,
I wanna do less of that,
and to be very frank,
the reason I wrote a
book called AskGaryVee
is it's my great ambition
to build enough brand
where I could come to
an environment like this
and just go right into Q and A,
because at the end of the day,
I think that's where the biggest value
happens in a keynote,
and so, what I'll do,
because I'm gonna assume
some of you and many
of you may not know who I am.
I'll try to at least
deliver on the promise
of giving a keynote, but
please rest assured that
I'm ready to go into Q and
A as soon as you guys are.
So, look, I think the thing that,
regardless if you're
a B2B or B2C marketer,
starting on your first day
or you've got a $100 million company,
I think the thing that
will really be important
for us to chat about first is
the thing that we're all connected by,
which is my obsession with attention.
Right, before you can tell
me how great your product is
or how charismatic you are,
or why you're so right about what you have
to say to the world, whether
as a person or as a business,
you have to get the person's
attention to tell your story.
To me, this is the most fascinating thing
that's happening right now in our society,
is that attention has never been more
changing, has never been harder to grasp,
I think for a lot of us
that have been in business
for a long time it's very
difficult to grab the current
changing landscape of
attention at the speed
of which it changes.
I spend eight, 10, 12, 15 hours a day
trying to audit and understand attention,
and even for me, there's so
many things still happening
that I haven't been able to
completely grab my hands on,
whether it's the depth of eSports,
arbitrage as a cultural phenomenon,
whether it's the blockchain,
whether it's all the
opportunity within AI and ML,
whether it's the emerging
AR infrastructure
in the Apple updates and
Google infrastructure,
whether it's voice, which I
speak a lot about right now,
on the Alexa, Google, and Apple fronts,
we're talking about a very different world
than our grandparents
and parents grew up in
as businessmen and women,
and more importantly,
as marketers and executors
and most importantly,
as actual practitioners of the craft.
I think the thing that
fascinates me the most
is how many people in here, I mean, to me,
when I think about how
many of you flew to be here
or are here to see me speak,
we, including myself,
we're so much further ahead
in understanding these things
because of our interest in it,
regardless of your success
at this point in it.
If you're sitting in this conference,
your intuition or curiosity or execution
around the modern day attention graph
and the opportunities
within it is so much further
accelerated than the 99%,
and to me, that's super interesting to me,
that we have such an
incredible opportunity in front
of us to trade on this opportunity,
and so, my question becomes,
how much of what you believe
and know about this moment
is around you reading
or consuming content,
and how much of it is that you're
actually executing within it?
If I can do anything to
start this keynote off with,
if I can lead with anything,
if I can impact you in any shape or form
to have one action item,
it would be for you to start
doing more of the thing.
Let me explain.
There's a lot of people in
this room who understand
the concept of KOLs or Facebook ads,
but yet, I don't think enough are actually
executing within those environments.
You know, it's unbelievable
how many of you have opinions
on these ad products and platforms,
yet aren't spending
and executing yourself.
I think the thing that
I spend so much time on
is I produce content and do social media,
because I wanna stay a practitioner.
I think of it as being
a mason or a carpenter
versus being an architect.
If you look at that industry,
a lot of architects grow up
getting their hands dirty,
and over time, they get
separated too much from the work,
where they lose a pulse on the reality
of the current infrastructure.
I'm fascinated by that.
That is the thing that I
try to stay grounded in.
If I can get everybody
here to make one more ad,
to create one more piece of content,
to A/B test six different
headlines on the same picture
in a Facebook, Instagram,
WeChat environment.
These are very important variables that
not enough of us are talking about.
And so, at the most high level,
I would hope to inspire
people to become practitioners
instead of pontificators in
the craft of the opportunity.
There is only one reason I
stand up here at this keynote
and have people wanna
hear what I have to say.
It's because no matter what
has been happening to me,
I've not lost my pulse on
the craft of what I do.
How many people here
have been following me
for longer than
a year?
So, one more time,
hands, I just wanna see.
Great, almost all of you.
Most of you, 60, 70% of you.
I'm a simple dude.
I basically only believe
in 10 or 12 things,
and I pump out an obnoxious
amount of content,
which means that over
the course of a year,
you're gonna pretty much
grasp what my pillars are.
I think the only thing that allows me
the luxury of keeping your
attention over the long haul
is my ability to stay relevant
to where the opportunities are.
The only reason after a year or two
that it's worth your
time to give to me versus
something else, it's because
I've had a good career
for 20 years of having enough intuition
on what consumers are gonna
do, but way more importantly,
I don't talk about Alexa
skills and briefings,
I make an Alexa skill and briefing
so that I understand it,
and I would tell you, there's
a huge lesson in that.
I think a lot of people,
especially if they get a level of success,
start getting too far away from the craft,
and you start building around
the raising the capital,
the exiting of the company,
the writing of the book,
you know, the speaking on the keynote,
you just get away from the work,
and I would argue that it's
never been more important
to stay on top of the work,
because every day it's changing, right?
To me, I'm running late this
morning to our first meetings,
and I quickly go on Instagram Live
because they just created a new update
where it allows you to
bring people into your
Livestream that are watching you,
and I did not feel
comfortable being here today
without trying and tasting
it and understanding
the functionality in case one of you asked
me a question about it.
I mean, it's an important insight.
It's an important insight,
and it is the absolute opportunity,
because when you think about
the way I think about it,
I talk about day trading attention,
and when you talk about
day trading attention,
I'm not a Wall Street guy,
I'm not a capitals guy,
but I understand the difference between
day trading and putting
something into a mutual fund
and watching it grow, right?
There's a very different speed,
there's a very different understanding,
and that's how I think about it.
My sign now says day trading attention.
A year ago it used to say marketing
in the year that we live in.
Why did I change it from
marketing in the year
that we live in to day trading attention,
it was because I realized, oh my God,
everything we're about to talk about
is happening even faster,
that even if you believe
in something for that year,
within that year, it's changing too much,
influencer marketing, and
Facebook, and YouTube,
and Twitter, and LINE, and WeChat,
this stuff is changing too fast
and we are not keeping up
with the subtle features,
because if you really understand this,
you know, you look at something
like Instagram Stories
or Facebook Watch or all these subtleties,
in those little sub-arbitrages, polling,
in an Instagram, in those little features,
in those little updates
are oftentimes the marginal
opportunity that is the
biggest difference between
growing your business and not.
And so, it's exhausting
and it's difficult,
but I have one very important
statement around this
for everybody, tough luck.
You know, no matter
how we want it, listen,
I wish that we never evolved from email.
In 1996, I had 90% open
rates on my email newsletter.
I was crushing it, life was good.
I had figured out email.
Then in the early 2000s, I
figured out Google AdWords.
I wish that never
changed, I figured it out.
I won on that, then YouTube came out.
I had one of the first long
form shows on YouTube in 2006.
I figured it out.
I liked it, I wish Twitter
didn't come along, but it did,
and then I spent 15 hours
a day tweeting all of you,
and then I grew into one
of the most followed people
on Twitter, and then Facebook evolved.
And, like, Instagram came
up, and Snapchat came.
Like, this is a never
ending game of attention,
distribution, and arbitrage,
and so I think the biggest
thing you need to understand is
the best product will always
win if people know about it.
Right, and so, I think
the thing that I spend
a lot of time on is I'm a
marketer, I like to market,
I understand marketing,
I'm a business builder,
I've built businesses.
I think there's an
incredible, interesting,
kind of graph between the
quality of your product
and how many people know about it.
So, for example, if
you're a great marketer,
and you listen to everything that I say,
and you get a lot of attention,
and your business isn't working,
a lot of times it happens to
do with your products sucking.
We don't spend enough time
talking about the product
or service you're selling, you know?
So, please, if you're
sitting in the audience
and you're looking for the magic pill,
or if you think that you're gonna be able
to siphon some information
that's gonna allow you
to play in the edges of the
arbitrage of opportunity,
please make sure you're
looking at your product
and service to make sure it delivers,
because if you follow my blueprint,
if you get results from
my ideas that you then
become an executor of,
if your product sucks,
all that I'm gonna do is
expose your product faster
and you're gonna go
out of business faster.
So, please start there, but after that,
please understand the following.
This is a golden era of
marketing for one simple reason.
The places where our
attention and our consumers'
attention are, are now
driven by marketplace bidding
dynamics, not by writing an
upfront check to get the ads.
Please understand this.
Please understand that
the biggest difference
for us as communicators
is we don't need millions
of dollars to do television and print
and outdoor and direct mail to hit mass,
we are trading on
marketplaces, Google, Facebook,
Snapchat, these are biddable marketplaces.
The reason this is the best time
is because those
marketplaces are underpriced.
Those marketplaces are
underpriced right now
because the biggest companies in the world
are not spending enough money on them.
You have to understand, when
there's a come to Jesus moment,
and the biggest brands in
the world properly spend
in everything that I talk about,
everything I talk about
becomes null and void.
When you have to spend
$48 CPMs to get in front
of potentially 1,000 people
in a feed instead of $7,
the mathematics don't work out as nice
for why I'm so excited.
When influencers and KOLs
start charging the proper price
for their product
placement and endorsement,
it won't be as fun of an opportunity.
And so, I continue to yell
at the top of my lungs
right now, how many people
here actually have been
following me for eight years?
Raise your hands, there's
not gonna be a lot,
but I'm just curious, go a
little higher, eight years?
First of all, thank you
for the eight of you.
Second of all, second of all,
you eight have a unique understanding
of me that many others
won't, and let me explain,
for you eight, that, I can
see two of you right now,
that you understand.
I was very loud, Gary Vee, in 2009, 2010,
but then I got very quiet for my standards
in 2011, '12, '13, and then I
started getting louder again
in '14, '15, '15, '16, '17, right?
For everybody else, there's a reason.
I am my most excited when I think
there's an arbitrage at scale.
If I had been making content in 1996,
I would've been talking and making videos
and audio and written word about email
until I put you into nausea.
Then I would've gotten quiet in '99,
'cause email had caught up,
and then somewhere around 2001,
I would have probably spent
24 months yelling at you
that this Google AdWords
thing is incredible,
intent marketing's incredible,
if somebody's searching to drink wine,
that's probably good to
buy for five cents a click,
and I would have yelled and screamed
for two to three years on Google AdWords,
and then somewhere around
2006, '07, it corrected.
Ah, dit, dit, dit, dit, dit, dit, dah.
Every single person in this conference
is going to regret not spending more money
on Facebook and Instagram.
Every single person in this,
I'm talking, and by the way,
I know some of you have
a B2B SaaS business
that you haven't been able to figure out
how to do Facebook ads,
but I know tons of B2B SaaS
businesses that are selling
top of the funnel and
conversion based sales every day
on Facebook at scale because
they're trying harder than you
to figure out the creative that
is the variable of success.
Please understand that the creative is the
absolute variable of success.
That it may be the word or
the picture or the video
that hasn't let you be successful
in Facebook, not Facebook.
And so, I sit here with,
as you guys can tell,
a different demeanor than
sometimes when I speak,
because I think it's very serious.
I think this is an enormous opportunity,
and I very honestly am excited that I know
three of you are gonna
email me in four years
and it's gonna be like,
Gary, you were right,
I didn't spend enough on
Facebook, God damn it.
So, now that we've established that,
I wanna talk about the thing that
excites me the most right
now, which is voice.
A lot of you have heard me
yell and scream about voice.
How many people here
have seen my enthusiasm
for voice, raise your hands, great.
I'm awfully passionate about it,
and I'm passionate about it because
of one of the more interesting
chapters in my career,
which is when I passed on Uber, twice.
At a four million dollar evaluation.
In the angel round for one of
my best friends in the space.
The reason I passed was, first,
'cause it was a side project
for Garrett and Travis,
but second, 'cause I didn't see it.
But why did I invest a year
later, before it exploded?
It was because I understood that Uber
was selling time, not transportation.
And more importantly,
the perception of time,
because if you've ever been
to New York City like me,
there's nothing more humbling than waiting
for your Uber and watching 500 cabs
that are empty drive by you.
Now.
Audio.
How many people here, in the last year,
have started spending more time listening
to my podcast and watching
less video because of it,
raise your hands.
Raise it high, I want
everybody to look around.
This is the insight that
matters to me the most.
Right?
The reason they've done that is because
what audio allows that video
doesn't is passive consumption.
You can listen to the podcast
while doing something else.
You can listen to the podcast in a shower,
while you're driving,
while you're working out,
it's time arbitrage.
Audio will be a huge
explosion for all of us,
in every one of our businesses,
because when you're communicating,
and hopefully you're bringing value
and not running a radio commercial,
when you're communicating
and bringing value
to your audience and building
awareness for yourself,
you're gonna be doing it in a
way that respects their time.
The reason I hate modern day advertising
is 'cause it steals time.
A pop up banner on your
phone steals your time.
You have to hit the X,
it's too small, it pops up,
it opens up, you're pissed
off, you try to exit,
and now you've wasted four seconds, which,
oh, by the way, means a lot to you.
It would be stunning to you
for you to realize how much
slower your internet that
you're used to in your office
or home has to be for you to feel it.
It's staggeringly a little.
And so, time only with health and money
and religion are now on the pedestal
of things that we care about the most,
and every technology that I
see that sells you back time
in exchange for your attention
will be the things that I bet on the most.
And that is why I am obnoxiously
bullish on voice, and when I say voice,
I mean I think everybody
here should start a podcast.
I just do, and in the Q and A,
I'll show you an example of
any one of your businesses,
how it could be a podcast,
if you'd like to ask me,
and two, I think everybody
here should start thinking
about what it looks like to
develop a briefing or a skill
inside of Amazon, Facebook, excuse me,
Amazon, Google, Apple, whatever
Facebook comes out with,
whatever the tech giants
from China come out with,
it is going to be the way you search.
In the next five years,
five years from today,
I promise you, you will
be blown away by how much
of your search behavior
is done with your voice.
As a matter of fact, one of
the most interesting stats
that I'm paying attention to is that one
in every four searches on
Google on a mobile device
is done through voice.
And if you have young children that play
in a YouTube environment on an iPad,
my son, when he was at three,
could navigate the
entire web through voice.
So,
look.
My point here is very simple.
We are ridiculously lucky,
because we get to navigate
through this time.
For anybody over 30, and
especially if you're over 40,
you really recognize that,
because, for the over 40 crowd in here,
we lived pre-internet in a lot of ways.
The scale is remarkable,
the impact is high,
the upside's enormous,
and to be very honest,
I think most of us are
just taking it for granted.
I don't think we understand the impact
of how much the opportunity is real,
and for me, it becomes
disproportionately compounded
because you're actually
at this conference.
You're actually part of a
very small interesting group
for me, which is, I know
how big the opportunity is,
I know that 99% of people
have no idea it's happening,
you do, so you're part
of 1% of the whole thing
that understands it's happening,
now it's yours to lose.
I would argue that if you are not able
to achieve what you
want to achieve in life,
and you're at this
conference during this time,
then you really mis-executed.
Then you really got into the things that
I worry about when I put out content,
which is you worry way too much about
stuff that does not matter.
That you're worried way too much
about other people's opinions,
which is the biggest reason
you don't take chances,
because you worry about how
people judge your failures,
then you're doing a lot of other things
that are leading to huge levels
of missed shots and missed opportunities,
and so that's why I speak so much
about being insular,
having the right intent,
because literally, fundamentally,
if you synthesize
everything I've just said,
non-action is the fundamental reason
that most of you will fail, at this point,
being in this room, at this
conference, during this time,
and understanding quite a bit
of what's actually happening.
Non-action, which if you
take all the way to the seed
of a human being is insecurity.
Which,
is probably the biggest
reason that I create content,
because I hope that you use me
as your shield to do shit,
period.
So, that's what I think is happening.
Audio's super interesting to me.
Feed dynamics and a mobile
device are the currency today,
it will continue to be for a little while.
Enormous things are happening around us
on blockchain and AR and
things of that nature,
they're all coming, they're
all circling around,
some things are much further
away than people realize,
I am very, very anti-consumer
VR in the short term.
If you asked me, this
great phenomenon that I'm
so obsessed with called the internet,
the only thing that
arbitrages it out is VR.
If we live in a full VR
world, then now what, right?
Cool, but nobody here
knows a single human being
that spends an hour in VR in a week.
Not for non-business purposes,
consumer behavior's not there.
My friends, for the people
that are the smartest
when it comes to tech in here,
the biggest thing that stops
you from being successful
is you understand that the tech is ready,
but you haven't factored
in consumer behavior.
The biggest reason that
so many super smart
technologists fail with their products
is they anticipate techs and
they understand that it works,
there's so many things that work right now
that are four, seven, nine years away,
because we're not ready
to use it that way.
Online dating worked
in 1996,
but it took another decade
before there was a stigma
removed from it that allowed
it to start having some legs,
and 10 years after that,
now it's mainstream, right?
That is basically what I do for a living,
day trading attention,
understanding behavior around it,
what are people gonna do
today that's meaningful
to the goals that we have?
Couple things that I wanna throw out
before we go into Q and A.
One thing that has come
up quite a bit today
since I've been doing
interviews and interacting
with people on social here in Singapore is
because I have a personal brand,
which, oh, by the way, is
such an interesting word,
'cause it gets people very
emotional in both directions,
I just wanna remind people that
hate people with personal brands,
it's just a slang term
for your reputation.
So, people that have a
reputation or a personal brand,
there's a lot of people asking me
if that's a requirement to
build a successful business,
and I find that laughable,
because I wanna remind everybody,
I wanna remind everybody
that 99% of businesses
don't have a personal
brand in front of them.
You know, I think that
it's a great to have,
I think if you are
charismatic or narcissistic,
or enjoy the attention,
it's a nice to have,
I super love it, I love
taking selfies with you
as much as you love taking it with me,
it brings awareness, it's branding,
but it is far from the reason why one
would be successful and it's
definitely not a requirement
to be successful in today's
business environment.
The requirement to be
successful is very simple.
Is your product good enough,
and do people know about it,
and do you have the
structure to get people
to know about it better than
the people you compete with
for the same share of attention
and money for that product.
It's very, very, very, very basic.
The biggest issue is, slash opportunity,
is the speed in which
it turns and changes.
And so, couple of the
things I wanna talk about.
Let's make it contextual to this audience.
I wanna remind most of you that you have
a disproportionate advantage
from most entrepreneurs
in the U.S., which is,
oftentimes, not always, because
of cultural differences,
but oftentimes, you get to see a preview
of what's happening before it happened.
When I think about my
friends that have built
successful businesses in southeast Asia
by simply paying attention of
what's happening in America
and then replicating some
version of it in the market,
it is literally the dream come true.
American entrepreneurs got mad
at those brothers in Germany,
right, who would rip off the
ideas and build a business.
I always was so upset about that.
I mean, I think Facebook has proven
that there's no ripping
off if it's a feature,
and I think I would also argue that
ripping off by looking
at a different business
in a different market
and then interpreting it
into your market is far from ripping off,
I think it's called smart.
So, I would highly recommend,
I don't know if it's pride,
which I think holds back a lot of people,
but please take advantage
for the disadvantages
one could think they have,
there's only five million here,
if you wanna do it in Indonesia,
there's a lot of people but
there's so many microclimates,
so that's, so many
different segmentations,
mainly in China, whatever you
would deem a disadvantage,
please understand you have
the greatest advantage,
which is 90% of things
are human, not cultural.
90% of things are human, not cultural.
If you're capable of
understanding the culture
of your consumer and
layer the cultural context
on top of the human thing
that is happening in America,
you are halfway home.
An unbelievable advantage
to be an entrepreneur in this region,
and watch things play out,
by the way, for free, no report needed,
no hiring Boston Consulting
or Bain and McKinsey,
by reading and watching
videos and downloading apps,
something that I don't believe most people
in this conference are
taking full advantage of,
or respecting enough of
how big of an advantage
that is, and to me, very honestly,
I'm quite selfish when I speak,
I dream in three years
from now, you email me,
nothing would make me happier than
getting an email from
somebody here who said
they had a $50 million
exit, because, you know,
they just looked at what
was working in America,
and they built the replica-ish of it here.
Please do that, please understand
how big of a deal that is,
and I would argue it is your
singular biggest advantage
in this market to be able
to be shown what will work,
and then allow you to interpret it,
oftentimes with very
little change in the model.
Cool?
Cool.
What else is interesting to me?
You know what's super interesting to me?
LinkedIn.
Let me talk about LinkedIn for a second.
How many people here are on LinkedIn?
Good, this will work.
LinkedIn's interesting to me.
I think LinkedIn is up to something
that I think will be
beneficial for a lot of us.
First of all, how many
people are in B2B marketing?
Raise your hands.
So, look, raise them higher,
because I see a lot of
half assed hands, higher.
Great, two hands, nice.
B2B.
I've said this before, I'll say it again,
'cause I'm not sure
how many have heard it.
Here's how I think about B2B marketing.
In every one of our B2B spaces,
there's usually a magazine or two
that is the leading B2B
magazine in our sector, right?
There's just a B2B magazine
that our customers read.
I think that's the thing
that you should attack.
I think you, as a company and a service,
should look at the B2B
magazine and deem that
your competitor, more than
people you compete with
to sell contracts to
clients, let me explain.
It is my belief that everybody in here
is no longer an advertiser,
but that everybody in
here is a media company.
So, I know a lot of you have heard me say
don't listen to what I'm
saying, watch what I'm doing.
I don't advertise, I act
like a media company,
and then from that, I
have top of the funnel
brand awareness that leads to my business.
I don't buy ads on Ad Age,
I don't sponsor things that can,
I produce content with my points of view,
act like a media company,
and they funnel into an
environment where I built
$125 million in revenue in AdWorld
without winning a single RFP.
Right?
So, I don't know what all of
you do in your B2B business,
but I would look at why
people read the B2B magazine,
and I would argue that
you need to start becoming
a media company for the sector,
and then trading off of the
top of the funnel awareness.
Let me explain again.
In 2006, this happened to me intuitively.
I started a wine show on YouTube
less than a year after
YouTube was launched.
I thought that I was
gonna make infomercials.
I thought my main plan when
there was a camera like that
in my office for episode one was
I was gonna sit there and sell you wine.
Something very interesting happened,
if you wanna go on YouTube
and watch episode one
of Wine Library TV, somewhere
in the first three minutes,
you can even see my face
take a little weird turn,
you can see me thinking,
because I realized that
this would never go away,
that this video would live forever,
and I realized that if I was shilling wine
that I didn't believe in,
that I could be exposed.
So, somewhere within
the first three minutes
of me ever producing a piece
of content for the internet
in my life, I switched
from being a salesman
to being a media company.
I would argue that most of the behavior
in the way that you produce content
has short term sales DNA
versus long term media DNA.
And this is the vulnerability
of why you're not getting
the returns that you're looking
for from this environment.
So, I would, please, implore
a lot of you to realize that
I believe one of the first
hires of your business
in the future is your editor
in chief of your business.
An actual media editor for a SaaS product,
or a consultancy firm, or whatever you do,
and so, this media mindset
is super fascinating.
Let me explain it in an
even more historical nature.
Do you guys know that
the Michelin Tire Company
in the early 1900s
decided to start writing reviews
of hotels and restaurants
in the countrysides of
Europe because people
weren't driving enough
and using up the tires
and stopping in their gas stations,
so they started reviewing
restaurants and inns
positively if they were further
away from London and Paris
to get the wealthy to drive out there
and stop by their stations
and use up their tires,
and that is why we, to this day,
have restaurants rated
three stars Michelin,
because the Michelin Tire
Company, 100 years ago,
executed on my thesis.
In the same vein, Guinness beer company,
after declining in pubs for the first time
around the same time,
realized that a lot of people were
talking about trivia at the bar,
and literally created the
Guinness Book of World Records
to get you to talk about
crazy records and trivia
in a pub and use the word Guinness,
so that you would subconsciously reorder
a Guinness in the pub.
This is super interesting to me.
I'm a very big believer that the future
has all of its seeds in the past.
And so, I implore all of
you to become much better
historians around how to use media
as a top of the funnel gateway
to sales around your business.
Once you understand that,
you will find far more success in LinkedIn
if you write a white
paper that helps lawyers
run their business and
then it's a gateway drug
to what you sell them,
than if you were to try to
just sell them an ad saying
free consultation if you use my firm.
Media DNA versus advertising DNA.
Media, again, you want
distribution in retail stores?
Write a white paper on LinkedIn,
15 things that retailers
need to do in 2018,
brought to you by your brand,
I promise you, you'll
be stunned by how much
inbound opportunity you
have in that environment.
Media, not advertising.
So, those are some of the
top of the funnel things
that are really on my mind.
I continue to execute, I continue to do,
I'm very fascinated by how much time
people spend dwelling and debating,
I think we glorify strategy
and we underestimate execution.
I feel like if you look historically
and rewind the biggest successes,
the strategy came from the execution,
and you did some Monday
morning quarterback,
I'm a real genius, in hindsight,
because I can manipulate how
I got there after the fact.
I'm gonna talk about so many
things in different ways
than the intent that it was at first,
because you don't even
realize that your strategy
came from it, because when you're doing,
the strategy is happening in realtime,
you almost forget why you were
doing it in the first place,
and so I promise you,
indecisiveness and debate
and pontificating and ultimately, ego,
is stopping so many people
from being successful.
And while I'm on that,
how many people have
more than 10 employees,
raise your hand.
Great, I think it's worth bringing up.
Hiring.
I'm super passionate about hiring.
How many people have
more than 10 employees,
raise your hands.
I think one of the biggest
flaws in most of your companies
is your own ego wrapped
up in being somebody
that's good at hiring.
I wanna tell this story,
'cause I think it's one of the most
fascinating things happening
in small businesses.
I'm stunned by how many small businesses,
CEOs, founders, or owners
think they're good at hiring,
and have made this a thing.
They've made it a thing
'cause they wrap their pride
in hiring, and here's what happens.
I feel like my EQ and people
skills are off the charts.
I am baffled by how many horrible hires
I've made in the last 20 years.
A lot.
So, when I think about my
intuition and ability and process
and deploy that against the masses,
I know a lot of you have made huge
amounts of mistakes hiring.
I so don't give a crap
what you think about me,
that I'm very comfortable
and excited about
admitting that I was wrong
and firing very quickly.
Most people sit on
people for a year or two,
because they don't wanna be exposed
at making a wrong
decision, and in that time,
enormous amounts of bad stuff
happens to your business.
So, and a completely random thing
from what I've been talking about,
if I can get one person
here to fire the person
they should be firing in
their business right now,
after today, I will feel very accomplished
on my entire trip to Singapore.
Who's got a question?
Great.
You see that, that was good accuracy.
What's your name?
- [Man] Melvin.
- Melvin.
- [Melvin] Yeah, and first
off, I would wanna say,
Gary, thank you so much,
because of what you did,
you changed my life.
If you remember, slightly
earlier this year,
you started a contest on TV--
- 2017 Flip Challenge?
- [Melvin] No, the GV, GV Podcast Contest.
- Yes.
So, at the point, I'm almost in the U.S.,
and I knew that by the time
that that thing's gonna happen,
I will be in New Jersey, New York,
so I was hustling really hard to get you
to pay attention me,
obviously it didn't happen.
- Yes.
- Yeah, alright, but,
but the good part was that what I did was
I did exactly what you told me to do,
or what you had been saying.
So, I had the hashtag,
I started tweeting everyone
who submitted their entry,
and I said, congratulations, I asked them,
this is my favorite Gary
Vee quote, what's yours,
and then I started getting reply.
And so, that was when I got a reply,
and that was when I restarted
my vlogging journey again,
so this is the third time I've
started my vlogging journey.
So, this time when I
started my vlogging journey,
boom, it happened.
People started paying attention,
I think you know him, Chris
Brogan, pay attention to me,
he tweet a lot my videos,
he even jump on a call with me
to do an interview, so that was great.
- That's awesome, he's a good guy.
- [Melvin] Yeah, so, first off,
I wanted to thank you for ignoring me,
because if you hadn't ignored me,
I wouldn't have thought of that.
- I love it.
- [Melvin] Yeah, so that's one.
Now, number two is that I think there are
three things that we have in common.
Number one, we have the
same favorite number.
- Five.
- Number,
number two, we have this, we
are born in the same month.
- Nice, November.
- Yeah, alright,
so, the other thing is,
I wanna say is that,
when I started my vlogging
again, this time around.
- Third time.
- I started getting attention,
and I started getting discovered,
and now companies start calling me,
people start calling me and say that
can you do videos for me?
So, now I'm here today,
and I'm devastated.
Why, because you are talking about audio.
(everyone laughing)
Alright?
- Yes.
- [Melvin] So, my question is, right now,
I'm beginning to crush it,
if you know this actually,
I said to you earlier on
Twitter that I'm not coming here
because I'm executing on what
you say and I'm crushing it,
I have no time, but I'm here
today because I wanna see you,
I wanna say thank you to you.
- Thank you.
- And so,
my question to you, it's basically this.
For someone who is really getting traction
in terms of video, people
started paying attention.
- Both.
- Well, yeah,
yeah, I know.
- Both.
- [Melvin] But would I be, would I be,
so what would the--
- Both.
- [Melvin] Strategy be?
- [Melvin] What would the strategy be,
what would I do with podcasts?
- I don't know.
(audience laughing)
- Okay.
- But let's talk about it.
- First answer is both.
- [Melvin] Okay, obviously.
- Now, let me rephrase, it
depends on your ambition.
First of all, I love
going deep on what works.
Just 'cause audio's rising
doesn't mean video's dead.
You know, it's so funny,
we've been the same for a very long time.
We, as humans, consume
content in written form,
in audio, and in video.
Whether it's TV, newspaper, or radio,
or blogs, podcasts, and YouTube,
it's the same game.
So, nothing's gonna die.
If you have real ambition
to build a personal brand
that you wanna arbitrage opportunities on,
my answer is both,
because in 16 hours,
you can get a lot done.
You know, people always
say to me, do you sleep,
and this and that, Gary's
always pushing no sleep,
I mean, if you follow me carefully,
I talk about six, seven,
eight hours, sleep!
I'm not worried about you sleeping,
I'm worried about what you're
doing when you're awake.
16 hours is a lot of time to do damage,
and so, what would you do on your podcast?
Look what I did at first.
I believed in audio about
a year and a half ago,
I wanted to get in, I was busy,
I didn't have the
infrastructure I have now,
so what did I do?
I transcribed the Ask Gary
Vee video show into audio,
right, then I watched it,
it wasn't enough value add,
and it was made for video, so
it wasn't contextual to audio,
so my podcast was not
doing as well as it could.
Then on vacation, where I
had a little time to think,
I decided to rebrand it to
the Gary Vee Audio Experience,
which gave me a lot more flexibility
to give you guys original
content that you didn't
hear anywhere else, keynotes,
different things, and it took off.
You have to look at yourself
of what you're capable
of doing, especially when
you're a one man band,
and I don't know if you have
anybody helping you yet.
- [Melvin] Not yet, right now.
- So, as a one man band, what I would do,
is if you're vlogging, every day,
I would take 10 minutes of
something that you're doing
or talking about, not
show it in video form,
rip the audio, and make that your podcast.
- [Melvin] Got it.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you.
- Can you pass it on to the next question?
Question?
Your aim is not where we're the same.
(audience laughing)
- [Kenneth] Hi, Gary.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Kenneth] My name is Kenneth, so.
- [Kenneth] I'm very good,
very good, how about you?
- [Gary] Super.
- Good to see you here,
I would like to say a
big thank you to you,
although I did not follow you for years,
but in the past six months,
a lot of things have changed.
I'm writing a book, it's
called Modern Industrialist.
I, in fact, emailed you, but
I guess I have not hustled
enough to email you a lot of times,
but because of that,
of you ignoring again,
I realized that I need to do something,
and I took the action of
document versus create.
Because, for me, I'm a
marketer, marketing consultant,
I always think of crazy ideas, but,
and I don't go into documenting.
So what I did is, because of
my book, Modern Industrialist,
I interviewed 15 mompreneurs that I put
into my book that I personally know,
and because moms love to share,
they start referring mom,
other mompreneurs, but I could
not put them into the book,
and that's where I created
my Facebook Live With Lee
every Monday, and I
document it, document it,
and I interview them, and
it's growing and growing.
So, my question to you
is how should I bring it,
scale it up from there, and personally,
I own a creative marketing company,
so how do I put it together?
- So, you wanna figure out
how to use the leverage
of the weekly show to build on top of?
- [Kenneth] Yep.
- What would you like to happen?
Would you like it to be a gateway drug
to your creative shop,
do you wanna build a SaaS
product for mompreneurs?
Or do you wanna become a personal brand
and live as being the human
that makes enough dollars?
I think you have a lot of
flexibility of what you can do,
but this is where you
have to start backwards.
So, for me, the reason
I think I'm winning is,
for me, backwards, I'm more
interested in my legacy
than making money, which
is why all of you like me,
because I'm trying to win
you over by giving you value,
not get a short term sale,
which is why it's building legacy.
So, all my behaviors work backwards.
I just gave you in one
second three viable options
on the back of this,
do you have a clear answer to that,
or is that something you need to debate?
- [Kenneth] I,
because there's a lot
options that I could do,
which I'm working on,
but it's not coming back
to me as fast, because.
- How long have you been
doing the live show?
- [Kenneth] I'm doing episode 15,
so I'm going for my 16 of
doing on a weekly basis.
- Hold on, one, five?
- [Kenneth] One, five, yes, yes.
I just started, yeah.
So, because of that, yeah.
So, I'm going on and on, I'm not stopping,
and it's growing, and
it's not just locally,
it's also into U.S. and a lot of traction,
people start referring.
- Yeah, it's called Facebook.
- Yes.
Yeah, so, I'm continuing that,
and getting a lot of traction,
getting partners coming,
and also to sponsor for my book,
so that's what I'm working towards,
and I would also like
what you have mentioned,
is to put it as a media, so
I'm also attracting partners,
companies, to come in, to maybe, like,
mompreneurs, they have their own business.
- Can I give you a good piece
of advice that's good for everybody?
- [Kenneth] Yep.
- The sooner you monetize,
the quicker you give up the leverage.
- [Kenneth] The question
is how to monetize.
- Yeah, I understand.
So, and the answer is,
I really wish you didn't give a shit
about monetizing just yet.
So, you know, there's a
lot of ways to monetize.
You just rattled off several,
and I rattled off several.
So, I don't think you have an,
are you having trouble
closing the opportunities?
- [Kenneth] I guess
the struggle is because
I wanna bring up value,
I wanna push this mompreneur
movement all around,
and to drive this, rather than
focusing on the monetizing,
but monetizing is still
our bread and butter.
That's why--
- But they're very
different things, right?
One of the things that
really works for me is
I don't wanna monetize any of you,
I have an agency that works
with the top 100 brands, right?
So, couldn't you monetize
with what you're doing
and continue to build equity
with the mompreneur community?
- [Kenneth] I could do that, just that,
I have to speed up, and also.
- But why speed up?
Dude, you've done 15 episodes.
You're four seconds in.
What are you trying, where are you going?
What's the rush?
I mean, that's the punchline.
Right?
Do you think it's gonna go away,
do you think you found some
sort of rare, you know,
pot at the end of the rainbow
that's gonna disappear?
I'm asking.
- [Kenneth] I feel that's unique,
coming from a man, coming from a dad,
interviewing mompreneurs.
- So, what, are you scared about a bunch
of dudes here trying to
talk to the mompreneurs?
- [Kenneth] No.
So, I guess it's to, to
find out, to find out what,
because I have my own
creative marketing company,
it's like what you've
been doing, VaynerMedia,
you're doing your
business, at the same time,
I feel that being an
author, writing my book,
interviewing mompreneurs, is
kind of like my Superman time,
that I get to do all this
thing, which I love to do it,
but at the same time, I
have to be Clark Kent,
I have to do all the work
and get my bills paid,
which is fine, but.
- The problem is,
you can't monetize
Superman to be Superman.
You followed?
- Yes.
- That's the problem.
You're trying to sell a
logo on Superman's suit,
and it's gonna look really stupid.
You following, or no?
- [Kenneth] Yep.
I get it.
- The answer is, you don't monetize it.
- [Kenneth] Got it.
Thanks.
- Because,
because two things will happen.
One, you're still gonna
monetize as Clark Kent.
I spent, do you watch Daily Vee at all?
- [Kenneth] Yes, yes.
- You know how I always talk about, like,
you're not seeing any of
it, 'cause you're not.
13 hours a day that you see nothing of,
me in meetings with clients,
sometimes I'll do a fast
music and, just to show you,
just to remind you I'm
actually doing, but,
I don't think it's super fun content,
I think it's a waste of
your time to watch me
in B roll be in 11 hours of meetings.
You know, I'm very good
at being Clark Kent,
and I have no interest
in monetizing Superman,
you're trying to monetize Superman,
which is gonna be the undoing of both.
- [Kenneth] Got it, yep, I understand.
- Cool.
- Okay.
- [Radul] Hey, hi, Gary, my name is Radul.
- How are you?
- [Radul] Very pleased to be here,
and also, I need to start
by saying big thank you,
because I've been following
you for about one year, maybe?
- Thank you.
- [Radul] But really needed
some of those principles.
Maybe I read too many bullshit stories
of get rich overnight and kind of,
I was having that illusion in my brain
that it's supposed to be fast,
and I think that the top
thing that I took from you
is that, look, it takes time.
- Yeah, it's really interesting, right,
because my personality,
and I'm sure some of you
felt this the first time
you saw me, my personality
seems so bullshit.
(audience laughing)
And it's ended up being
my biggest strength.
Because I have that kind of pizazz that
all the bullshit people say
it's gonna happen fast have,
I'm able to get your attention,
and then I trick you into going slow.
And then you actually get what you want.
- [Radul] Yeah.
It works.
I guarantee.
- Sure does.
- [Radul] So, thank
you very much for that.
My question is, and I'll work through it,
'cause I'm not sure I have
it clearly in my head.
So, basically, I've been
doing headhunting and
human resources, executive
search, for about four years.
- I like it.
- [Radul] Very specific to a field,
which is supply chain and logistics.
- I like that, too.
- [Radul] I started a podcast about
two or three months ago,
which is going really well.
- That makes sense.
- It's called Leaders
in Supply Chain, so I'm
trying to do what you--
- Let me tell you why I think that,
notice how I said that
makes sense, super narrow,
you know what's so funny, it's
how I think about Singapore.
I think having five million citizens
is the advantage, not the disadvantage.
Everybody's so quick to build here,
and then go and do
Indonesia and other parts,
that you forget that if you win the entire
five million market, you
have a real business.
I love podcasts in,
in very narrow, supply
chain, are you kidding,
nobody, everybody thinks
they have to make, like,
consumer, the meanwhile is,
if you get the right 800
people listening to your, 800,
if you get the right 800 people listening
to your podcast, your headhunting
business is gonna explode.
- [Radul] Yeah, and it's starting,
but I guess it's just the, so,
I think it will need a
little bit more time,
but it's happening because I'm engaging
with really C level people that,
'cause it's also creating that platform
that this industry
doesn't have, currently.
- It also is media, so your
ability to email somebody
who's the decision maker
at a company to be a guest,
who nobody would ask to
be a guest of anything,
and now they become aware
of what you do on the side,
give Superman away for free,
watch Clark Kent make money.
- [Radul] Yeah.
So, I guess all of this is happening,
I think it needs still a bit
of time, a lot more time.
- Of course.
- [Radul] But I guess where I'm,
I'm kind of struggling over,
I guess what my question
is, so, on one side,
we are selling headhunting.
So, basically, you recruit
the best for your business.
- I understand.
- Which is HR.
Then, on the other side,
I'm specialist in an industry
which is logistics supply chain.
So then I'm kind of, 'cause
sometimes also people,
especially if it's very senior level,
so I've been getting
with some board levels,
but I went on the side
of the podcast to them,
and then they don't necessarily remember,
they remember, okay,
that's the podcast guy,
they don't remember you
as the headhunting guy.
- Yep.
- [Radul] So, during the podcast,
I do the bit on the industry,
I do the bit on the HR, how
do you recruit your people,
and I try to make that connection.
So, I guess where I'm struggling with,
and I don't know what's the
best way moving forward,
I think it's gonna work if I keep it
to supply chain and logistics,
I'm also considering,
shall I keep it to Asia,
so, expanded, and saying,
doing business in Asia,
to make it a little bit broader.
- I mean, you mean the show?
- [Radul] Yeah.
And also the business, then I can also,
I can then bring the headhunting business
to expand, as well.
- Do you feel like your
business is ready to do that?
- [Radul] I don't know.
- Yeah, I feel like it isn't.
- [Radul] Yeah, probably not, yeah.
- Right.
(audience laughing)
You see what's happening, right?
It's the same reasoning,
like, the get, quick, fast,
it's his question, guys,
it's the same shit.
It's everybody, it's the same
game over and over and over.
I get it, and even when you
have some level of success,
it's hard, I get it.
I get it.
I live it.
I have way more opportunity than you
could ever wrap your head around.
But I stay disciplined on what I can do.
Why didn't, we've been
registered to do business
in Singapore for three years.
Why is VaynerMedia not
here, we weren't ready.
Was my brand ready, yes.
Would we get business, yes.
Would it deliver at the
level that I thought
I needed to to create 20 year success, no.
You're on to something,
and this is what happens
to a lot of businesses,
I look at it everyday.
You're on to something,
and now you're tasting blood in the water
and you're getting greedy.
Because you see it,
and especially if you're
hearing it from something
like this, and you're like,
wait a minute, this is gonna,
you know, like, you're
compounding your confidence,
which is making you go wide
when you should be going deeper.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Hello?
- Hello.
- [Moshad] Hi, hi Gary, my name is Moshad,
and like what you said,
80% of your content today
is more or less on YouTube,
that's that 30% I kind of absorb,
I actually collected this box for my mom,
but firstly, I wanna tell you,
I'm actually gonna quit my
job to do something like
DRock or Word of Mouth Marketing Company,
but before I pass this on to my mom,
is that your new K-Swiss
shoes, that's my question.
- These are my new K-Swiss shoes.
- [Moshad] Alright, awesome,
awesome, awesome, thanks.
- [Camillia] Hi, Gary, I'm Camillia.
- Hey, Camillia.
- My son got me onto you.
I didn't even know you were around.
- Thanks a lot, Camillia.
(audience laughing)
I'm kidding.
- Sorry about that.
Well, I.
- Good news,
99% of people don't, so, go ahead.
- [Camillia] It's okay,
the word is getting around.
- They will.
- Right.
I'm a WOMologist, and a lot
of people ask me what I do,
I'm actually a specialist
in word of mouth marketing.
- Word of mouth.
- [Camillia] Word of mouth, offline,
because I'm not an online person.
I've never been, and, but
he's gonna get me on it
because of you, okay,
so, thank you for that.
- Thank you.
- [Camillia] But, what do you call it,
it has always been a stigma
that for many entrepreneurs
that word of mouth marketing
is a very weak activity,
and yet, a lot of, what do you call it,
material says that it is the most powerful
form of marketing, and I took it on.
For the last four years, I did research,
I started a business group for it,
and I found out why it
was the most powerful.
But my question to you would be
where do you see it in the
next three to five years?
How does, how would it
grow, how would it evolve?
Word of mouth marketing in the market,
especially for entrepreneurs.
- So, word of mouth marketing
is what social media is.
- [Camillia] Right.
- All that social media is,
is the plumbing and infrastructure
that has created word of mouth marketing
to hit the scale that it's always had
in the invisible nature
of the conversations
that we have with each other in real life.
So, even my first book that
put me on to the world,
Crush It!, that I wrote in 2008,
most of it refers to word of mouth,
and then the book I wrote
in 2011, Thank You Economy,
is basically just about
word of mouth marketing.
It's about being extraordinary
to force word of mouth marketing.
I believe nothing sells
product and services
more than another human
being to another human being.
Where it lives, I think will continue
to go into this device,
not us talking, and I think that's great.
I think too many people want
us to talk to each other,
so I find platforms fascinating.
I find it fascinating that
we put a pen and paper,
somebody writing a letter, today,
as this incredibly great gesture,
even though we do it on here all the time.
We're putting pen and paper on a pedestal,
not the words that we're
exchanging with each other.
And so, I think word of mouth marketing
is basically the old school
term for social media.
I'm a buyer, to the end of time.
Until the robots kill us, I'm a fan.
(Camillia laughing)
- [Camillia] Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you.
(Gary laughing)
- Nice pass.
How are you?
- Hi, how are you?
Okay, I have this question,
okay, first of all,
I've been following you
for a few years now,
I think back from 2014, and
you completely changed my life,
and how I operated my business.
It was really tiny back then,
but we managed to have
really healthy growth
year after year, thanks to you.
- Thank you, thanks to you.
- [Woman] And the question is,
we're at a point where
we're in that crossroad
where we have to decide where we want
to either grow organically,
or we also have the option
to grow rapidly, as well,
because we have interest.
- And if you grow rapidly,
you have to take investment?
- [Woman] Yeah, because
we have interested parties
wanting to offer that to us, as well, and.
- Do you own the business?
- Yes.
- 100%?
- [Woman] So, that's the thing.
I'm, I just wanted to
hear your take in that,
like, if you have options to grow.
- Do you own the business 100%?
- [Woman] Yes.
- Do you wanna have a boss?
- [Woman] Not, it depends,
it depends on the angle,
because I do have a certain
angle that I want to get to,
so I'm just, I just wanted
to hear your take in this of,
do you, how do you feel
about growing consistently,
organically, on your own, but
it'll take really long time,
and somebody else might come in
and take away the opportunity, and.
- Do you believe that?
- [Woman] You never know.
I feel like I have a
certain value to offer,
and there's nothing like it at this point,
so I feel like I have that certain value,
and I have that following,
I have the trust and the loyal
of our customers, as well.
- If you can raise capital
to speed up your process
and to create bigger distance
between somebody copying you,
that's meaningful, and
you don't give up control,
it's a worthwhile debate.
80% of 100 million's better
than 100% of 40 million
from a dollar standpoint.
Just don't think that
just 'cause you sold off
20% of your company doesn't mean
that you're not gonna be held accountable.
Let me give you an example.
When AJ and I sold a piece of
VaynerMedia to Stephen Ross,
one of the things that I made required
is that I never had to have a meeting
to tell them how the business was doing.
- [Woman] Alright.
- You like that?
- [Audience] Yeah!
- It's a good one, right?
Now, he was worth eight billion dollars,
so he could give a crap ass.
You need to make sure,
whether you sell 1%,
you could sell 1% of your company,
and that investor might take up
a disproportionate amount of your time.
The biggest issue is time
when you sell a piece of your company.
Do you really wanna
prep for an entire week
every 90 days for an investor meeting
so you can justify your behavior?
- [Woman] Yeah, but the thing is,
I'm quite keen on taking that offer,
because it's much more
of a strategy partnership
that will bring up value to me.
- So let's talk about that for a minute.
Is it a human or is it a company?
- [Woman] Both.
Because, it's a company, yeah.
- Is the human that you're excited about
being a strategic value
prop to you an employee
of the company or owns the company?
- [Woman] Owns the company.
- Okay.
So you feel you'll get
value from this individual?
- [Woman] Yeah, both sides,
because they wanted to
invest because they wanted
to have us under their property as well.
- Sure.
- 'Cause that could bring
certain value to them, as well,
so that's why they want it, so.
- Of course.
- Yeah.
- How, I mean, you know,
as you can see, as we're digging,
there's no right answer to this question.
- [Woman] Yeah, there's
no right at all, yeah.
- I think the question
becomes how comfortable
you feel with them.
I think you need to make sure
you over talk expectations.
Young entrepreneurs often make the mistake
of only seeing the good
side of an investment.
And there's, nobody's giving you lots
of money 'cause they think you're awesome.
And so, you just need to be thoughtful.
The amount of people that
I've seen raise capital
when they didn't need to and
it destroyed their business,
is more than I'd like to say.
At the same token,
there's a ton of people
who would have failed
and gone out of business
without a strategic investment,
and then it turned into a huge success.
Here's what I would say.
Everything that's in your stomach
that you wanna ask and talk about,
do it before you sign that contract.
That's the mistake.
You sit on two or three
things that you just
think will work themselves out,
bring them to the forefront.
- Okay.
- Make sense?
- Yeah, it makes sense.
- I'm sure there's one
to two things that are in your head.
- [Woman] Yeah, a few things,
like you were saying
there's no right or wrong,
it's just, I have a certain angle
that I wanted to get to, and.
- What does angle mean?
Dollar amount?
- [Woman] No, no, no.
It's in, itself, the impact of the company
that I wanted to, because
the kind of impact I wanted
to get, I wanted to have
that certain impact,
the level that I wanted to
have it, I need a partner.
And that's what.
- Can I ask you a question?
- Yeah.
- The impact that you
want the company to have,
could you get to that
impact 11 years from now?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- So, then you have to ask yourself,
are you trying to get
to the impact sooner,
and you're putting that as a romantic
point of view in your head,
and are you giving up too
much to get there sooner,
because it's just one
bigger version of patience,
this is why I'm pounding
patience down people's throats.
And more importantly, is this impact real,
or is it manifested in your
head as a romantic thing,
you know, you gotta
think about those things.
- [Woman] No, it's real,
because the thing is,
with our company, we're
super engaged, because,
customers and our followers,
they don't see us as brands,
they see us as a friend.
So, that's how we built, like.
- Be careful, because, at scale,
that tends to go away.
- Yeah, I get that, yeah.
That's the thing,
we have to have a
certain balance somewhat,
yeah, as we scale.
- That was probably the thing
that scared me the most,
because,
if that's how your consumers feel,
it's almost impossible for
somebody investing in you
to being comfortable with
you doing the behavior
that makes that 100% pure.
They are thinking about the scale of that,
which then dilutes the energy of that.
- [Woman] It's not my voice,
it's the company's voice.
So, they don't see the brand as a person,
it's just, they feel like--
- I understand.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Woman] When they see the, like,
the people that runs this
company has a certain value
that they resonate to, so, yeah.
- Let me ask one last
question, and we'll move on.
Does the investor have any
say after the transaction?
- [Woman] No, not really.
- Good, then do it.
- [Woman] Yeah, alright.
(audience laughing)
- But just make sure you
define the not really part.
- [Woman] Yeah, because, no,
because they do have a certain,
they, based on the
conversations that we have,
they do wanted to offer advice,
try to bring up a certain value for us,
but, Gary Vee, ultimately,
it's still my decision,
'cause that's what they, they told.
- Ownership.
- Yeah.
- Good luck.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
Did we lose it?
There we go.
- [Shawn] Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Shawn] I'm good,
I'm good, and yourself?
Okay, I'm Shawn, I'm a digital
marketer from Malaysia.
First off, I took your advice,
and I started vlogging not too long ago,
and I'm already seeing work,
doors that I could never
imagine are starting
to open for me, and I only
have you to thank you for that.
I have a two part question,
first, my father owns a
traditional billboard business
with about 1,000 sites,
mostly along the highway.
I'm persuading him to
invest into it digitally,
I don't work for his business yet,
but I assume I will in the future.
Given your expertise,
if we became partners
today in this business,
how would you focus your resources,
and what would you, what
would your first steps be?
- What kind of business is it?
- [Shawn] A traditional
billboard business.
- Traditional what?
- Billboard.
- Yeah.
- So, your dad owns billboards.
- [Shawn] Yes, 1,000
sites along the highway.
- Which is rad, is it, are they digital?
- [Shawn] No.
It's too early.
- So,
I would probably make the capital invest,
if I took over my dad's
business or became his partner,
I'd probably take the
capital risk up front
to take them digital,
'cause I think that's gonna be required
to get the value out of that outdoor.
I would also look to diversify,
'cause I'd be too fearful,
you're a young dude,
I'm too fearful about self-driving cars
and all the things that
happen over the next
20, 30 years that would disproportionately
decrease the value of
the asset that you have.
So, my intuition is
that I would diversify,
I would either sell off half the boards
and then put it into
building a media company,
or I would reinvest all
the profits each year
into building some sort
of digital complement
to a traditional product like that.
- [Shawn] Okay, got it.
The second part to the question is
as an extension to my vlogging,
I plan to start a series
of interview videos
of podcast sessions with
people within the same field
to talk about what they do,
and I was wondering, this
is, starting my luck here,
would be my first guest to officiate this?
- So, I won't, but.
- [Shawn] Ouch, see, that hurts.
- But, if you do 15
episodes, I'll be your 16th.
- [Shawn] Okay.
I already have 22.
- What's that?
- [Shawn] I started my
vlog, like, 22 episodes,
but I will start 15 interviews after that,
and you'll be my 16th?
- You've done 22 vlog episodes.
- [Shawn] Vlogs.
- But if I was listening carefully,
you asked me to be a
guest on your new podcast.
- [Shawn] Right, okay, got it.
- So, that, I'll wait 'til I'm the 16th.
- [Shawn] Got it, thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
- Hello?
- Hello.
- [Terrance] Yeah, hi,
Gary, my name is Terrance,
and I'm 20 this year.
So, just one question for you,
I've been listening to
you for about a year now,
and I'm just trying to figure out,
as a 20 year old without any experience
in my parents' business,
I've wanted to build a video, a blog,
an audio podcast, but I
don't have the experience
to actually do it.
So, which answer should I focus on,
building up the experience in a business,
or should I go direct to
help market a company?
- Well, listen, if you started
a podcast and a video blog
about being experienced in the craft,
that would be bad,
faking it.
But if your podcast was about
the experience of learning the craft,
you'd probably have a lot of
20 year olds following you.
So, I don't think it's about
getting the experience,
when I talk about I built
a business for 15 years
before I came out, right?
I say that because that's what happened,
but I have a funny feeling
if the internet was around
when I was a kid, like this,
I might have started documenting
my journey right away.
I just wouldn't be walking around
like I was a business building guy,
I would be talking about being a young,
ambitious guy who used
to sell baseball cards
and now I'm about to do it for wine,
and I would take people
along with my journey,
that's my biggest problem with people
that don't have experience, they're lying.
They're lying that
they're business experts,
or my favorite, you're a
20 year old life coach.
'Cause, you know, you've lived life.
So, to me, I think you
can start the podcast
and the video blog, I
mean, I wish I did that,
because I, there was, I
probably cried, cried,
50 times in the first 10 years
that I worked with my dad,
'cause they were very painful fights.
And that would have
been incredible content
that I wish you guys could watch
if you're in a family business,
because it turned out okay,
and it would have been really cool
to see how that happened and why,
and how I was able to
give more than I took,
and how I loved my dad
more than the money,
and how I thought about what I could do
in my 30s and 40s and it's
okay to lose in my 20s,
but I wouldn't have walked around and said
I was a marketing genius because
I thought I was gonna be.
- [Terrance] Yeah.
So, start documenting my journey
to becoming a businessman?
- Hell yeah.
- [Terrance] Got it.
- If you think that's interesting.
Maybe you're not comfortable
enough in your own skin
to talk about all the failures,
which is the most interesting part
of documenting being a
20 year old businessman.
But if you are,
there's some people that are gonna listen.
The truth always wins, my friend.
That's all you need to know.
- [Terrance] Alright.
Can I get a hug?
- A hug?
- Yeah.
- Sure!
- [Terrance] Awesome!
(everyone cheering)
- [Gary] Are we gonna
take a picture of the hug?
(audience laughing)
- Let's start a vlog now, okay.
So, my journey to becoming a businessman.
- He's liar, he said
he was gonna do a hug,
and now he's doing a vlog.
- Okay, okay,
I'm sorry!
(audience laughing)
Thank you so much, Gary.
- You're welcome, you're welcome.
Alright, after this question,
let's send it over there,
'cause they're about to start a coup.
Go ahead.
- [Man] Thank you, Gary,
I flew in from Malaysia to see you.
- Thank you.
- Okay.
So, okay, I am a little
bit of confused right now
in our business, because,
we're in the hosting business.
- Hosting?
- Yes.
- Hosting websites.
- Not only websites.
- Right.
- But several hosting.
- Understood.
- [Man] Kind of services.
So, when we are saying,
because Google, Amazon,
IBM, all the big giant out there,
and when you're saying marketing budget,
we can't compete.
- No way.
- And if
we can't afford the content,
the blogs, the video,
they are everywhere, so,
do you have any advice for this?
- Well, who, who's using you now?
- [Man] Okay.
What we are doing is--
- How many customers
do you have?
- [Man] Okay, about 500.
- Okay, great, so we have
a great situation here.
The first thing that, if
I was your new partner,
and I was brought in to do
the marketing as the partner,
the first thing I would
do is figure out why
those 500 people are using us,
and then that would be the
content that I would distribute.
Don't ever mistake money
as a competitive advantage.
Because plenty of big
companies throw money
directly in the trash.
So, there's a reason 500
people are using you.
Now, it may be that you're very good at DR
and intent based marketing
and you're winning on
Google AdWords, I don't know,
then, after I figure out
why you have 500 customers,
then I would ask you the next question,
which is, how long have
you been in business?
- [Man] About five years.
- Great, and how many
customers do you have
that have been with you
for three years or more?
- [Man] I do not have the exact numbers,
but I guess it's somewhere about 50.
- Great, then I would survey them.
And listen, they may stay
with you because it's passive,
once you're on a server,
you don't wanna mess it,
but I would look for the insight.
Is it the homegrown, you
know, high touch, small,
I don't know, but once
I understood why people
were coming to us and staying with us,
I would make all my
communication around that.
I'm never worried about
who's got more money.
When I had a liquor store
doing three million dollars
a year, 10% gross profit,
300,000 before expenses,
my marketing budget in
year one was $14,000.
For the year.
And https://www.wine.com,
the first version,
raised $130 million.
The amount of days that
I spent worry about them
was this.
Fuck Google.
- [Man] (laughing) Okay.
So, essentially what you're saying is when
I'm going to look into the insights,
and the next step, still
content marketing, is it?
- Content always, so, are
you doing conversion based,
like, is that how you're
getting your customers?
- [Man] Okay, we are just
ranked organically on Google,
and recently, we started blogging.
So, that's what we are really doing,
is a little bit of Google
AdWords and Facebook marketing,
but they don't really work so well for us.
- Have you done Facebook ads against
employees of companies
that you wanna get on?
- [Man] Sorry, I don't get that meaning.
- When you run a Facebook
ad, you have to target it.
It's not putting a piece of
content and hitting boost,
that's 17 years ago.
It's making a piece of
content and targeting
who you wanna reach.
Do you do the marketing?
- [Man] Yes, I'm the one who,
doing it, yeah.
- Good.
So, when you've done Facebook,
you said it doesn't work for you.
When you post it, are you
running ads against the content?
- [Man] No, we do it
directly to the landing page.
- I understand, but when
you post it in Facebook,
are you just posting it organically
to the 30 fans you have?
- [Man] No, we run ads, certainly.
- Good, who are you targeting?
- [Man] Okay, we figure
out who are our customers,
so, okay, one of the major
customer is the Forex Trader.
- Is the what?
- Forex Trader.
- Okay.
- Because they run robots.
Okay, they use our service, so,
we target exactly what
that ad interest are,
the Forex signal, the MetaTrader
4, those kind of thing,
but they--
- Have you,
have you,
have you done influencer
marketing on Instagram
since so many of those Forex people
wanna build personal brands?
- [Man] That's the next
step I'm going to do,
after listening what.
- You should definitely
pay all these characters
that think they're building
a personal brand in Forex,
and I would do sponsorships
with them as human beings.
It's gonna work.
- [Man] Okay.
- Good.
- Alright, thank you.
- You got it.
(audience applauding)
Pass it over there,
okay, this guy stole it.
He broke the rule.
- [Yurt] I, I've actually
tried to contact DRock
and the whole thing, Gary Vee,
and of course I know that you're coming,
but I volunteered to
actually be the personal
Uber and tour guide to
tour you around Singapore,
but I didn't get a reply,
similarly to audience before.
- DRock's a really bad guy.
- [Yurt] But Ben actually replied to me,
but he said no, but it's okay,
but I still rented a car,
and I'm with the rented car today.
So, I have a few questions.
So, I'm actually a content
creator, my name's Yurt, so,
I've met many businesses,
especially in the FM BIM industry,
that still don't understand
the importance of social media.
I know it's a simple no
brainer to many people here,
but, can I ask you,
what will you tell them,
in a one minute kind of pitch to tell them
the importance of--
- Let me give you
a good piece of advice.
- [Yurt] Thank you.
- Never sell the unsellable.
I would tell them that it works better
than anything in the world,
and then if that took more
than a couple of minutes,
I would go knock on the next door.
The biggest problem is, guys
and gals like you and I,
we get caught up in trying
to convince somebody.
I've never spent a minute trying
to convince somebody of anything.
We're in a place where
a lot of people still
don't know that this works,
or they ran one Facebook
ad and it didn't work,
and now they've decided
Facebook doesn't work.
My answer is I don't.
I don't try to convince people.
I tell them it works,
I tell them millions of businesses have
made it work for them,
and then I hope that they're
interested in, if you,
are you trying to get people as clients?
- Yep.
- Good.
There's unlimited clients.
- [Yurt] Got it.
- So, what too many
people do is they dwell,
and they try to convince nine clients,
and that would have taken up the time
for them to ask for 500
other people if they were
interested, and they would
have landed four clients
while they're waiting to get nine of them
to still debate with them
on their fourth meeting,
trying to convince them.
Got it?
- Got it.
And can I have one more request,
I actually bought one of your
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right-Hook,
can I get a signature from you right now?
- You can if you pass
it over to that section.
(audience laughing)
Anybody in that section.
- [Yurt] Pass it to them and come forward?
- Correct.
- Awesome.
- Hello.
Go ahead, it'll start working.
Go ahead.
- [Woman] Yeah, I have a
professional service firm.
I'm doing B2B market research,
I started interest in
researching in TALON,
and then I expand into Indonesia in 2015.
- Hold on one second, go ahead.
- [Woman] And now it's time for me
to expand my business again.
But because I'm in the
professional services,
when I have to expand my business,
I also have to add accounts.
And I actually prioritized
two options for me right now.
The first option for me
is to expand into Vietnam,
and the second option is to,
you are pay, okay,
the second option is to
start a tech startup.
- What?
- [Woman] A tech startup.
- Why is that your second option?
- [Woman] Because I think
it's a big opportunity,
and it's the area that
many clients are focused,
it's the pinpoint, and nobody
has actually looked into that.
- Okay, if you start the tech company,
are you gonna bring in a tech co-founder?
- [Woman] Yes.
- And give them 50% of the business?
- [Woman] No.
- Okay, so let me tell you
the most fascinating thing
when people decide to go from something
linear to a tech company.
They wanna do a tech company,
and usually they hire
somebody to build the tech,
'cause they don't wanna
give up any of the equity.
This is the number one mistake
that entrepreneurs make
when they go into the tech business.
They hire a firm because they
don't wanna give up equity,
but when you're in the tech business,
you're in the tech business,
and you better have a real tech partner,
and unless your tech
partner has minimumly 20%,
up to 50%, they're not gonna care enough,
and you also have to understand that they
have disproportionate leverage,
because they're the tech
co-founder in a tech company.
- [Woman] You mean if I have to give them
half of the shares to make it work?
- I would tell you that you don't have to,
but I have seen an unbelievable amount
call it, now, maybe 5,000 businesses
in the last 10 years that
have gone from I do this,
but now I'm gonna do this tech product,
'cause I see the pain in my business,
I'm gonna hire this little
firm to build my app
or product, or I'm gonna have a CTO,
but I'm gonna pay her or him
and I'm not gonna give them equity,
and what most people
don't understand when they
go into the tech business
and build a tech product,
they're at the mercy of the tech.
Tech is great on paper.
It's a very different business
when you're actually in it.
So I just wanna make sure,
and the reason I'm going down this path,
is I wanna make sure that you realize
that if you're going in the tech business,
you're gonna lose the leverage.
Unless you're a developer.
Does that make sense?
- [Woman] So, as a
professional service company,
is there any other option
to scale the business?
- Yeah, so, I think if you're
gonna build a tech platform,
that's a great way to scale the business,
I just wanna make sure you're
going in eyes wide open,
that you're going into a
totally different business.
Building a tech platform
in any professional service
is completely different than being
in the professional service business.
Right, having an agency
that builds websites
for clients is very different
than starting WordPress.
So, I'm cool with it,
as long as you really know
what you're going into,
and I've just seen too many
people lose their first business
by trying to build a scalable business,
when they have no idea what
they're actually going into.
And I'm just trying to
make sure you wrapped
your head around, I'm
now in the tech business,
servicing the professional
service industry
that I know well, which
means that you do not
have the leverage anymore,
the architect and executor of the tech
does, 'cause what if they
build something for a year
or two and then they leave?
Like, it's very important you get there.
Or, you go into another market, right?
Which is more of what you know,
other than you have to
contextualize the market
that you're now in.
Both are viable, just don't
be naive about the first one,
because most people are.
- [Woman] Yeah, but it had
been something in my mind
for so long time, I wanted
to do it so many times,
and I actually went to a master degree in
big data analytics to learn how to code,
so that I could start it.
- That helps.
- [Woman] It helps, it's
actually give me a very good
connection the right
tech guys that I should.
- [Gary] I love that.
- [Woman] I should partner with them.
- [Gary] Okay, so let's
go back to the open,
now that I have that data,
you're debating between
expansion to a new market
or building the product?
- [Woman] Right.
- [Gary] And it seems like if
you don't build the product,
you'll always regret it?
- [Woman] Yes.
- [Gary] So, let me give
you a good piece of advice.
I'd rather you be broke than be regretful.
- [Woman] I don't want to regret.
I just wanna do it.
It's like, no matter what, no lie,
my choice already go to,
like, building a tech product,
I already make decision,
I just wanted to hear what other
people would think about, because.
- [Gary] Why?
- [Woman] Because, it's like.
- [Gary] Who gives a
shit about my opinion?
You've already made the decision.
- [Woman] Yeah, but at
least you can give me
a good perspective on which
I should be careful about.
- [Gary] I'll give you a good perspective,
I 100% believe in
building the tech product.
- [Woman] Okay, you just
confirmed my decision,
thank you so much.
(audience laughing)
- [Woman] First things first,
thank you very much, Gary Vee.
You really, really changed my life.
The first time I actually saw your video
was the 5 Minute Plea To Do.
Prior to that, I've been giving myself
a lot of excuses for failing
and for not taking action
and for procrastinating,
but after I saw that video,
I went 100%, 200% into
just focusing on doing.
Now, my question is, as a
freelance digital marketer,
I face this challenge of
getting a lot of information,
and having to keep myself up to date on
what's happening on each and
every one of the platform
in order to deliver a lot of value
to my customers, and so on.
So, how do you actually do that,
how do you stay on top of
things, and yet, deliver value?
- By working a lot.
(audience laughing)
- [Woman] So, how do you manage that,
within 24 hours a day, how
do you split your time,
do you organize, do you
systemize, what do you do?
- I'm definitely not organized.
I, this is the biggest reason
I built my personal brand,
the number one reason, to
stay being a practitioner.
I don't have the luxury
of reading a headline
about Instagram Stories
or Snapchat filters
or Facebook Live without using it,
because I have too much
to gain on that side,
so it's a self-fulfilling prophecy, right?
I built my brand by being a practitioner,
which makes me a better strategist,
which makes VaynerMedia better,
and it just keeps feeding each other.
So, A, have you started
building your own profile,
are you interested in that, or no?
- [Woman] Yes, I am.
- That would be my biggest advice.
Every time you see something new,
make sure you build a
profile on everything,
and then every time
you hear a new feature,
use it immediately, which
will then systematically
make you a very good strategist.
You know, and then the other
thing I would tell you,
is don't beat yourself up.
You need time for your family,
you need vacation time,
you don't have to hustle like Gary Vee,
don't beat yourself up.
Do the best you can.
I don't know everything about everything.
I probably know a lot more about a lot
of this stuff than most people,
but you don't have to be
everything to everything,
you just have to be
better than the next girl.
Do you know what I mean?
What people make a huge mistake about
is they create a fake
standard in their head.
The way to win in business
is the same way to win in sports.
You just have to be a little
bit faster than the other guy.
Right, I don't have to be
100% on 100% on everything,
I just have to be a better alternative
for the same money than somebody else.
So, I would tell you to be very,
and then you gotta think about how much
deal flow you have, how satisfied you are,
I think the biggest thing is
that people beat themselves up,
they hold themselves
to some fake standard,
just make sure you're being
reasonable with yourself.
- [Woman] Alright, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Man] How's this, sir?
Gary, how's it going?
- Super well.
- [Man] Awesome, thank you for being here.
So, quick question for you.
With our brand, we have a,
we run luxury fitness
gyms and beauty clinics,
and we're fortunate enough
to have a pretty big budget,
our budget for digital marketing
is about $100,000 a month,
so it allows us to test a lot, right?
My question for you is, ultimately,
we're trying to drive
sales and revenue, right?
- How much, how many,
how much of the 100,000 is being done on
bottom of the funnel transactional
membership versus brand?
- Are you ready?
- Yes.
- [Man] All of it!
- That's the problem.
(audience laughing)
No, that's the problem.
- No, no, no,
I agree with you, too,
that's where I'm going, so.
- I figured.
- [Man] We have about, a
cost of revenue KPI of 10%,
meaning, if we spend 10
grand, we make 100 grand,
which is reasonably
efficient, my question is,
we're in agreement, our company,
that we have to spend
more on top of the funnel,
and we do have a lot of KOLs,
we do have a PR network,
we have celebrity ambassadors
and stuff like that.
- Can I give you the answer
to what you're looking for?
- [Man] Yes.
- Make the 80 cents on the dollar work
like the last 100 cents on the dollar,
so that you have no risk
on the 20 cents of a dollar
to do the high risk,
high reward activity that
you need to take it to the next level.
The answer always in this situation,
is taking a step back and
scrutinizing your own ability
to go on the real DR focused dollars
to cut 20 cents off the top,
and make the 80 cents work
like the prior dollar worked,
and then you're basically in
no risk, high reward zone,
and then you cruise.
So, it's not mindlessly saying, okay,
we're gonna take this framework,
it's about becoming
way better at the thing
that got you here to
give you the error cover
to the take the risks that
will get you to the next place.
- [Man] So, what you're saying is,
for short term loss on
conversions and revenue
for long term brand building
and more top of the funnel then, right?
- No, what I'm saying is don't lose any
short term sales conversion,
just get 20% better at that,
so that you have the 20% to play with.
- [Man] So, reallocate the other 20%
once we're able to grow
for more top of the funnel.
- Correct, take 20 cents on the dollar,
and spend 20,000 a month making a video
that is your Dollar Shave Club,
that could then take your CAC
on your DR stuff way down,
because you've built a brand,
but still make your 80 cents on the dollar
convert at the 10X, now it has to be 12X,
to make the old numbers work,
then there's no pressure from your CFO,
your ambassadors, or your CEO,
because now you've bought
yourself the freedom
to take risks, because
you made the 80 cents
act like the former dollar.
- [Man] Cool, thank you.
One more question, can
I get a selfie with you?
- Yep.
- [Man] Alright, here we go.
And who am I giving this to?
- Whoever you decide to.
- [Man] I'm gonna be biased and give
it to our account manager on Facebook.
- That was very inside baseball.
- [Man] Former account manager, actually.
- Hey, man.
- [Vlad] Hey, Gary, I'm Vlad.
- Hey, Vlad.
- [Vlad] Thanks a lot
for being in Singapore,
it's awesome to have you here.
My question is, so, you've
been spending quite a bit
of time in Asia lately,
Hong Kong, Singapore,
so, in your opinion,
where does the next wave
of media and tech innovation come from?
Does it come from Asia,
a lot of people say,
say a lot about China, does
it come from the U.S. still,
somewhere else, where do
you see the world going
in this respect?
- Can I ask you a question?
- [Vlad] Yeah.
- If, whatever the answer
is, what are you trying,
let me go a little bit, the
answer is from everywhere.
You know, I don't know,
I'm fascinated by the
stardom of entrepreneurship,
and what it means, for example,
I'm fascinated with this
dream I keep having,
that there's some 13 year
old girl in India right now
that so looks up to Elon
Musk that she's gonna
do something so crazy, and
I'm so pumped about that,
that's so incredible, right?
Anyway, the answer is everywhere.
The places that it's conducive
to happen is mainly America,
mainly mainland China,
a little bit of Europe,
a little bit of southeast Asia,
a tiny bit of South America,
so it's gonna be kind of
a lot of the same players,
because of the financial impacts,
the entrepreneurial branding
within those ecosystems,
the macro and micro economic scenarios,
there's a lot of different
things that are happening.
But I think the more
interesting question for me is
why are you asking?
- [Vlad] Gotcha, so, I
guess for those of us who
build our businesses it's
important to know where
to focus on, do you
focus on the U.S. market,
do you focus on the China market?
For those of us who are
employees and have careers,
where do you build your career towards,
to U.S., to China.
- I see.
So, look, I think they're
two very different,
if we're talking about the
two kind of superpowers,
they're both very different,
and both very similar.
They have a lot of things going for them,
and they have plenty of
shortcomings behind the scenes,
right, and for America now,
in front of the scenes, right?
So, I think,
I think the thing that
you need to debate is
what feels more natural to you as a human.
What are you more comfortable with?
Are you more comfortable with
an aging superpower empire that
is more purebred capitalist,
but is at maybe somewhere
between the third
or fourth quarter of its empire years,
or are you more interested in China,
which is in the beginning
of its empire run,
but has, your name's Vlad?
- Yeah.
- You know,
it's very hard for guys
named Genazi and Vlad
to completely be super
comfortable with any
level of communism, even if
it's disguised as capitalism,
right?
- Yep.
So, you just have to make
a decision for yourself,
as a human, my parents,
I've never been back to the Soviet Union,
because there's such negative feelings
for what went down there for my family,
that I would never, I
don't feel, even though,
so, I think China runs its country
like most successful businesses.
Some mix of capitalism, and
when needed, dictatorship.
VaynerMedia is far more
similar to China than it is
to the United States.
As for the human question,
you just have to ask yourself
where you'd rather live.
Both are gonna be just fine
by the time you die.
(audience laughing)
- [Vlad] Gotcha, thanks a lot.
- You got it.
(audience members yelling)
(Gary laughing)
- [Harry] I finally caught one.
Hey, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Harry] I'm good, thank you, I'm Harry.
We're from Malaysia.
We're actually aesthetic company.
- A static?
- Aesthetic.
Like, beauty clinic.
- Got it, got it.
- [Harry] We've been running
the business for four years.
For the past three years,
we've been using traditional
marketing, and this year--
- What do you defer,
what you consider traditional
marketing, direct mail?
- [Harry] Like, word of
mouth, brochures, agents,
and this year, we're starting
to get into digital marketing.
- And what do you call digital?
Social or Google or banner
or programmatic or what?
- [Harry] We are actually
trying to go into Google,
YouTubes,
SEO,
and social media
at once.
Right now, we're actually working on it,
with where we sell knowledge about it,
and I have these questions for you,
I would like to get some advice from you
on how can we podcast
our thing.
- Podcast?
- Podcast, like,
any advice on the trends on podcasts.
- And so, you want a podcast, why?
- [Harry] Like, a video.
- But why do you wanna do it?
- [Harry] Well, we wanted to, like,
showcase to our consumer.
- What you're doing?
- [Harry] Yeah, what we're doing,
and to make them understand
better than what we've
been trying to do, back demand.
- Okay, so the first thing is,
the way you've been doing
marketing traditionally,
is far more sales oriented.
You've had an agent resell,
you've done brochures,
you're doing selling.
A podcast is the furthest
thing from selling that I know.
It's over here, it's called branding.
Sellers,
for four years or three
years, hate branding.
You know why?
It costs money up front,
and nothing good happens.
For the first year.
So, first and foremost, I
wanna make sure that you
know what you're getting yourself into,
which is, if you start a podcast,
it's gonna take up a lot of time,
it's gonna cost some money,
and very little is gonna
happen in the first year.
So, somewhere around nine
months after you start
your podcast, you two are
gonna look at each other
and say, Gary Vee is an asshole.
(Harry laughing)
As long as you know that,
then I'm excited for you to do a podcast,
because that over time branding,
if you do and execute a good podcast,
will have very big effects,
but before you jump into podcasts,
since you've never even
done digital marketing,
I don't want you to go too far out
and just do it because
I said audio's good,
I want you to be grounded in
what you're doing and how.
You're such a heavy sales organization,
that I wanna make sure that you know
what you're going into, do
I think the sales on digital
can do better than your brochures, 100%.
Do I think the agents are
reselling right and referring?
I would triple down on that,
'cause that's always a good sales engine.
Right, yes, they get a piece of the pie,
but they're basically a workforce, right?
But I would get really good
at Facebook conversion ads,
and very good at SCO, and mainly SCM,
to be honest, more than SCO,
but before you begin to really
be committed to podcasts,
now, if you've got the
money to do all of it,
and you're okay with
wasting money and time
and year one on the podcast
to have a little bit more
opportunity in year two,
then that's great, but
you have to be smart,
and think about it from
a practical standpoint,
not an ideological standpoint.
- [Harry] I have another question.
- Sure.
- [Harry] Well, we're trying
to figure out our budget
into digital marketing into.
- As much as you can afford.
- [Harry] As much as we can afford.
Should we spend it equally in Google?
- You should spend 50% of it up front,
tasting everything and then
double down on what's working.
So, if you're gonna spend 100,000,
spend 50,000 in the
first three, four months,
try a lot of different things,
and become good at
understanding what's happening,
and then double down.
- [Harry] Do you think it's recommended
if we use YouTube as a channel
to do the conversion rate,
do you think it's possible using YouTube
to, for convert?
- Sure.
I mean, of course, but it's difficult.
Now, there is a product
that you should look at.
There's a way to target people with
a YouTube pre-roll video,
that is based on what
they searched on Google.
I think it's an incredible
product for all of you.
Google, YouTube has a
pre-roll video product
that you can target against what people
are searching for on Google.
So, as you can imagine,
if I'm searching on
Google how to drink wine,
or wine things, even if I go to YouTube
and watch Jets football videos,
it's gonna service me wine ads up front.
If somebody's on Google
searching beauty or spas
or the words you know, your video,
even if they're watching
kitten videos on YouTube,
being a pre-roll is gonna convert better.
This is what I mean about
being a practitioner
versus a headline reader.
Gotta know these nuances to be successful.
- [Harry] Can I have a last request?
We would like to have a wefie.
Is it possible?
- A what?
- [Harry] A wefie.
- A wefie, like,
we, in a selfie?
- We, together, yes.
- Yes, okay, that sounds cool.
Bring the mic up, oh,
you're gonna ask a question?
Then I'm gonna have you bring it up.
Anybody over there want, okay.
Go ahead.
Yeah, we can do it now.
- [Elkar] Okay, so, first
thing that I want to say,
is a big thank you.
- Thank you.
- [Elkar] So, for everything
that you've been doing,
the content that you've been putting out,
so inspirational that first
thing to express on this,
this exchange is gratitude.
- Thank you, brother.
What's your name?
- [Elkar] My name is Elkar,
I'm from Brazil with
business here in Singapore.
- [Gary] I'm listening.
- [Elkar] Okay, so, we're
running a VR startup
here in Singapore.
- Okay.
- B2B.
- Okay, good.
- [Elkar] And it focus
on the luxury market,
and as you may know, VR
is so in the early stages,
and we don't have, even
in the world or U.S.,
big success cases, large scale,
that can make sales a
little bit challenging.
If you're doing, we're doing well,
we just want to see if you
have any thoughts to say.
- I do, I have some
real thoughts on B2B VR.
I'm very much a big fan
of you tying your business
very close to experiential
and event marketing.
The place where you can find budget
is when brands and businesses
are activating in real life
at big events where VR
experiences are the draw
for them to get people
to come to their booth
or their exposition or their,
it is the only place that
I think is really viable
in a B2B environment for VR.
- [Elkar] So, that's where we're going,
because we're selling boats, yachts,
so, the big advantage point is boat shows,
so there's a place for us to, so we try,
we've been in Europe, like to talk to.
- Or, or, to be a little more creative,
as well, just high luxury,
high affluent areas where
you can do activations.
Art Basel is a place
where a brand or company
may wanna activate a VR yacht experience,
just because of the rich
people that are running around,
so you should map the 100
biggest rich people events,
and then reach out to the people that have
exhibited there in the past and see
if they want a hook to draw people in.
- [Elkar] Okay, that's a great idea.
When are we talking to the
shipbuilder, for instance,
right, so one of the
challenges is actually
to express other VR
cases, because, for them,
I think that it is completely new, right,
so, it's difficult for us
to see, to prove our pitch.
Any ideas how can we
bring those guys on board,
even though we don't have
other cases, U.S. or.
- You mean they're
looking for case studies
of other people that did it?
Yeah, I mean, this has
been my whole career.
The answer is you don't have them.
Same answer I gave that nice Uber driver.
As soon as they say, I need
a case study to move forward,
they're not in the VR business.
Got it?
- [Elkar] Yeah, makes sense.
- Make a big list.
When you're selling the future,
the answer is always make a big list,
'cause you're gonna get a
lot more nos than yeses.
- [Elkar] Okay, thank you so much.
Just one last thing, you
have the VaynerBeta program,
can you show a little
bit more about it, or.
- It's $25,000 a month
for us to do the marketing
for small businesses,
and it's a very watered down version
of what VaynerMedia does
for the biggest brands.
But it finally got to a place where
I believed enough in
it to actually sell it.
So, I think it's ROI
positive in a $300,000 macro
for small and medium sized businesses,
but obviously, not that small.
$300,000 for content and
distribution in social networks
is for a business doing some real revenue.
- Thanks, thanks so much.
- Awesome.
Can you give me the mic?
- [Man] Gary, Gary, five more minutes.
- Oh, you have, what?
- Five more minutes.
- Okay, good, this way, here,
give it to me, 'cause
I wanna give it, yeah.
Yep.
Nice.
- [Man] Or if you would
like to take it longer,
it's okay, it's up to you.
- Hey, Gary.
- Hey, brother.
- [Man] Speaking of that product,
there is a lot of, for me,
on social media, there's a lot of,
sorry, I fucking hate
public speaking, by the way.
- No worries, nobody's judging.
- [Man] So there's a lot
of shit that I see on
social media, it just
seems like people are just
churning and churning
and churning content.
I can see the reason why
people are hiring you
for their product, when
would you advise people
to kind of step back and hone their skills
and sharpen the sword, versus just, like,
it was a big thing that
everyone said today
is take action, take action, take action,
but there's obviously a time to sharpen.
- To be thoughtful.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
How do you make that.
- Let's make it a little
bit more selfish for you,
what are you trying to figure out?
- [Man] Alright, so I was, I
transitioned recently from,
I was in the fitness space,
I was a fitness influencer,
I was one of the, in the U.K.,
amongst the first kind of
young people to get really big,
and that kind of took off
on Instagram, on Twitter.
I then got sick of that industry,
and transitioned into the
content based, so, film and media,
previous to that, just
a prerequisite that,
I created a business,
like, an app for discounts,
a niche discount app in
the U.K., and it blew up.
Got bored of that, so, like,
got bored of fitness,
got bored of the app.
Transitioning,
and,
I kind of, I'm at the
point where I'm like,
right now I get up at four a.m. every day,
I'm studying film, I'm studying media,
and everyone around me is just like
always create, create, create, but, to me,
this is a time for me to sharpen my sword
and get my content to a level where it can
actually gain attention.
- I like it.
- [Man] I just wanna know when,
when, when, when you have done that,
'cause you pulled back on your
content body for eight years,
when are you deciding
to pull back and learn
and then to execute.
- For me, based on the
content I'm putting out,
it's when I feel like there's something
really meaningful to talk
about, then I wanna get louder.
Right, like I talked about earlier.
For you, it sounds like you're
doing original creative,
I'm asking.
- Yeah, yes.
- It's more like nonfiction?
- [Man] Yeah, nonfiction.
- To me then, it would be
when you feel it's ready.
Right, I don't think your,
now, what I will say is,
don't be scared to put
a little bit out there,
remember how I, or I did
that in an interview,
I didn't say it on stage yet.
Nobody remembers your losses.
George Lucas had movies before Star Wars.
You know, so I wouldn't
be super duper scared
of putting some stuff out there,
we're not gonna judge, that was crappy,
now you can't win on the next thing.
The other thing is you
could be very thoughtful,
and put out little pieces of content that
are parts of the story, Tim
Ferriss sold 4-Hour Workweek
because he used Google and
tested six different titles,
or four, I don't remember the story,
but he saw consumers'
intent around that title,
and it really worked.
I see a lot of the same happening
in original content online.
You could run really smart shit,
I would create a fake Facebook page,
some other brand that's not
gonna be your coming out party,
put some content there, run
$50 worth of ads against
the demo you think you're reaching,
and look at the quantitative
and qualitative feedback,
and it might give you some insight
if the sword is sharp enough
to take out of the shed.
See what I mean?
- Yeah, no, I get it.
- I think there's a way for
you to use it as offense
instead of looking at it as detrimental.
- [Man] That makes sense.
- Because, to your point, and
it's using your own words,
there's so much being put out now
that people are forgetting,
like, our attention span is so zero,
there's very little damage
you can do to the IP,
compared to the way it
plays out in your head.
I always tell all my friends,
nobody really gives a shit.
You know, you do, 'cause it's your baby.
It's why I put out so much content.
I think it's all good enough,
and if it's not the greatest
thing for the world,
that's okay, learn from it, I'm
putting it out there, right?
For me, I wanna get it out there, but,
you know, I think you
should use it as an offense.
- [Man] Nice, I appreciate
that, thank you.
- You got it.
- [Micheal] Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Michael] I'm good, thank you.
I'm Michael, from Perth, in
Australia, three of us came out.
- That's awesome, thank you.
Know it well, grew up
in the wine business,
been there plenty of times.
- [Michael] The Swan
Valley to Margaret River?
Beautiful, beautiful.
- I know it well.
- [Michael] This one's
a little bit off topic,
a little bit, over the last year or so,
I've been going down a bit
of a philosophical road,
thinking about life,
could be a midlife thing,
I don't know, and I notice that you,
I think that you're
probably one of the great
philosophers of our modern age, I think,
away from branding, away from marketing,
and I've loved your
content with Ryan Holiday
and stuff like that.
I'm wondering if, at some stage,
you may write a book,
away from, as I said,
the marketing and social media stuff,
and more about sort of your life lessons,
like the famous three
words, you're gonna die,
that sort of stuff.
- Yeah.
- [Michael] Good.
I'll buy it.
- I think yes, and I think you clearly
kind of see what's going on.
I think I, look, I'm writing a book
called Perfectly Parented,
it's a parenting book.
- [Michael] So it's, you are writing.
- I am writing that.
I think of doing some pretty
hardcore philosophies,
and then blending it
down into a little bit
more tactical in subject matter,
I think I'm gonna evolve, right?
I think even if you look
at early Wine Library TV,
I'm starting to throw
life lessons into the,
it's a wine show and I was doing it,
right now I'm into this marketing thing,
but my intuition is yes.
- [Michael] Yeah, that's great,
'cause I think 500 years
from now, whenever,
I think you'll be
remembered as a philosopher
more than a marketer, I think.
- You know, I think my ego's
very happy with you right now.
(audience laughing)
- [Michael] Ego is the enemy, remember?
- But I would tell you that
it's how I think of myself much more.
I think my stuff is very
heavy, philosophical,
what saved me from being too
heavy is my love of execution,
and I think I've forced
myself lower down the funnel
of my philosophies to make
them tangible and useful,
but yeah, I think I have
heavy themes in that world,
which is why it feels native to you,
and I do think that the people that,
if you listen carefully to even today,
people are getting a lot more value out
of my structure of thinking
than I gave you some tidbit,
you know, I love when people are like,
Gary Vee, you suck, you know, I love this,
this is my favorite, why
don't you give us like,
an actual piece of advice,
enough of this hustle and go,
and la la la, and I always
laugh, I'm like, dude,
and I reply, 'cause I love
it, I'm like, dude, Google it.
You can Google anything tangible.
You wanna learn how to use hashtags,
you wanna learn how to
edit YouTube videos,
create Snapchat filters?
You don't need a guru to
sell you an $80 eBook.
It's free, it's called
https://www.google.com.
To me, I think the stuff
we talk about philosophical
is imperative, 'cause it
becomes your life's strategy,
which then dictates your activities,
like, him not being
impatient and going wide
is disproportionately more
valuable for his business
than me telling him to use, you know,
RED in a post on LinkedIn
that will convert
you know, 1% higher.
That matters too, but
nowhere close to the stuff
we were talking about earlier.
So, I appreciate it.
- [Michael] No worries, and,
I've got on my phone the You're Gonna Die,
it's a very hard one to
explain to the kids sometimes,
though, when they see it.
- It's powerful, right?
- [Michael] Yeah, oh, it is, it is, yes.
- It's, I don't know what
everybody here is thinking,
the reason that lovely lady in the back
with the tech product, right,
I'd rather her fail on her tech product
than regret never doing it,
because the regret is gonna eat her alive.
And that's why I think about
you're gonna die, like,
I don't know what you guys are thinking,
but whatever the hell you wanna do,
I highly recommend you do it,
because if you spend time
with old people like I do,
you will figure out real fast,
it is your biggest vulnerability.
It will be the thing that kills you
when you can't do anything about it.
Regret is scary.
It's as scary as it gets.
- [Michael] Is it okay to get a Perth crew
kind of selfie with the
three of us and yourself?
- Sure.
- Cool, thank you.
- Cool.
One more, are we done, or?
- [Jack] Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Jack] I'm fine, I'm Jack
from Take Charge dot Asia,
so, we actually very
passionate on education.
So, I would like to get your view,
how do you see we can evolve the education
from now to it's, to the future.
- [Gary] You got it, so, one more time,
the education is what, one more time?
- [Jack] How do we evolve the education?
- Which education, what kind of education?
- [Jack] Higher education.
- Higher education.
So, I think higher education
is in a very vulnerable place,
because I think most
people in higher education
don't understand that the only thing
they're trading on is brand,
and as we start seeing
the biggest and best
universities in the world start creating
these products that are
diluting their brand,
right, which we're seeing a lot of now,
Stanford and Harvard selling courses where
people can say on
LinkedIn they went there,
even though they took a course.
I think the way higher
education is gonna evolve
is the professors
themselves are gonna start
getting huge leverage to
go direct to consumer,
and start trading in that way.
So, I think, if you have
passion for the institution,
versus the actual education,
the money making entity
known as a university,
well, then I would change the
business model very quickly,
because it's got a real vulnerability
over the next decade because
of the decentralization
of information, right?
So, I guess my question is,
is your passion lie in
the university itself
being successful or education
itself being successful?
- [Jack] It's actually the 100
years old education system,
we want to make a change,
even we are small, yeah.
- For what purpose?
- [Jack] I just feel that
the youth, or the millennial,
they just somehow need
some guidance along the way
to actually discover
what they desire in life.
- And you feel that modern universities
and intuitions are good at that?
- [Jack] No.
- Right, so,
so,
do you think it has anything
to do with the financial
benefits of being a university?
Because that's the question, right?
I think we all agree that this notion that
four years at university is becoming
this amazing guiding light for millennials
to find what they're passionate about
has 100 years of being
proven to not be true.
So, my question becomes,
with higher education,
is what's the purpose?
I default into the
purpose is to make money.
Which is not in the vested
interest of the user,
which is a vulnerable model.
If your passion is to help young
people find their passions,
I have a funny feeling
your default wouldn't be
into saving the institutions
known as universities.
Now, that's the interesting debate, right?
I feel that,
unfortunately, universities
have manifested
into incredibly self-serving machines,
and they're so broken that
I've gone so on the other side,
and I can't speak to
other parts of the world,
but in America, they've become
the worst thing on Earth.
Kids are getting
unbelievable amounts of debt
that they can't get out of,
and aren't being put in
a position to recoup it
within the first 20 years
of them being out of it.
Now, I know there's other
rules in other places,
so, I know a lot of us
are from different places,
but if you're,
if you're telling me your
passion is to help kids
find their passions, I would
use a blank piece of paper,
and reinvent a new model,
I have a funny feeling that
whatever you come up with
is not gonna be something
that the traditional
universities are gonna like,
because it's gonna break
their financial system.
- [Jack] Yes, exactly.
- So, now the question is,
do you wanna find a new business model
for a traditional institution
because that's what
you do for a living right now,
or do you wanna go on a quest
to reinvent the opportunity,
those are two very different things.
- Quest to reinvent.
- Good.
So, I'm an investor in a
startup called MissionU,
which is a different business
model where they educate,
right, and for free,
but in return, the students
give 15% of their salary
the first three years of their career.
I think what Adam's doing there is trying
to rethink the way this is all played out.
But I still think it's
self-serving interest, right,
produce people that, if
you think about that model,
produce people that will
actually make money,
so that I can get back my 15%.
You know, I question the whole thing.
Now, I question the whole thing 'cause
I was a terrible student,
I was super self-aware of who I was.
I would tell you, if you
really wanna achieve your goal,
you need to create a model that
gets to six to 10 year olds,
and you start finding a way
to teach self-awareness.
If you can figure that out,
you will achieve your goal.
- [Jack] Okay.
Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome.
I'll go more.
- [Man] Okay, but, you
know, maybe you know this,
all these guys want to
have a picture with you.
- Listen, I'll stand here
until tomorrow and just leave,
and then.
- No, no, no,
all these guys want to
have a picture with you.
- Yeah, but if, you're in charge, not me,
I'm, I'm just.
- Okay, so.
Do your job.
- So, which one do you want me to do?
Okay, good, hello.
- [Woman] Hi Gary, hi Gary.
- Hi.
- [Woman] Okay, in every businesses,
there's the supply and the demand side.
- The most interesting thing
that I've heard somebody
say in a long time,
'cause you're 100% right,
and it blows my mind that
almost nobody talks about it.
- [Woman] Okay, so, here's my issue.
I don't have any problem
with the demand portion.
Okay, the minute I go out there,
I open my mouth, I'll get the business.
- You don't know how to fill the pipe.
- [Woman] Yes, and I don't
know how to duplicate myself.
- Because you can't.
- I can't!
- I don't know if you heard.
(audience laughing)
- [Woman] Yes, I know that, but I need to,
I really, really need
to automate my business
and duplicate myself,
so that I can go home and have a holiday!
- I understand.
- So, what, do you.
- There's only two
things holding you back.
Your inability to operate, or your ego.
So we just have to dissect
it with a couple questions.
What do you sell?
- I'm in consulting.
- Great.
Why haven't you hired
more people to consult?
- I have.
- Good.
- [Woman] But they're just not up to it.
They're just not up to the level,
they're not, and--
- Hold on, hold on.
Up to whose level, yours or the clients'?
- [Woman] The level that I set as a basis
to benchmark as what I go
for, it's money service.
- So, so, you, real quick,
who's hiring these people?
- [Woman] Me.
- Okay, so let's play this game together.
(audience laughing)
- [Woman] Alright.
- What's about to happen is you're about
to get exposed to yourself,
and then you'll be able to win.
You're playing the very fun game
of you've got a big fucking ego.
I mean it.
You've gotta wrap your head around this.
You're hiring, you've created an arbitrary
benchmark that nobody's hitting
because you have put
yourself on a pedestal
at the mercy and the detriment
of building a bigger business,
because you wanna self-fulfill
that you're so much better.
Play with me.
You can't, think about what you, go ahead.
- [Woman] I'm not willing
to lower my standards.
- So don't, don't scale, then.
Be a one woman show.
- [Woman] I believe I can do more,
I believe we should duplicate this.
I mean, I've got the models,
I've got everything there.
I've basically templated
everything that I do.
So, all you need to do
is take the template,
follow the SOP, and let's
go out, hit the market.
- How many employees have
you had at the height?
- [Woman] 12.
- And how many do you have now?
- [Woman] Two.
- And was it customers firing or,
them?
- Me.
- You.
- [Woman] And at one point,
early this year, everyone left,
and I'm fine with that.
- Why?
- [Woman] Because they realized that it
was the wrong place for them to be.
And I realized that I can't,
there's no point for me to keep anyone
when they can't do the
job, and I'm, I'm prepared.
- Have you thought about the possibility
of you being a great
consultant but a terrible boss?
I'm asking, I'm asking.
- [Woman] I have that reputation, I know.
- Okay.
(audience laughing)
So, thanks for answering.
Look, I think you have,
I'm being serious with you,
and the reason I went right
at it, I want you to win.
It's a game of ego, and
what people don't understand
is that is the problem for all the,
the reason I've been able
to scale VaynerMedia,
many think that I have an
ego, I play on confidence,
which is what allows me to scale,
because I don't hold
everybody to an arbitrary
metric that has no reality other than
what's playing in my own head.
To me, if you're the one firing,
or they're quitting 'cause
the work environment
is exhausting because you
keep pounding the drum
of some fake Mendoza
line of quality needed
that you are the judge and jury of,
and it's some interpretation
of how you decide
they follow the template,
you're just scratching your
own ego of how great you are
at the detriment of your business.
The reason I have 800
employees and high retention
is I don't hold any of
them to my standard,
because they don't need to be me
to build an actual business.
You need to decide if you wanna build
a one woman shop or an actual business.
And can I tell you something?
There's nothing wrong
with the one woman shop.
The way you'll scale is
you may charge for content,
you may write a book,
you may start getting paid more to speak.
You don't, maybe you don't,
you know what I mean?
And even when I say it,
when I see you react,
you don't need to build a
40 person consulting shop,
because maybe you don't like it.
It's not that you're a bad person,
it's that you don't wanna
lower your standards,
and if you're stuck in that,
well, then monetize a different way
by expanding more around you,
versus trying to build up the
actual business around it.
You know what I mean, and that's okay,
it doesn't make you a bad person,
as a matter of fact, you'll
probably be disproportionately
more successful, 'cause
you're being self-aware,
and enjoying being the one person band
and making your money that way.
You don't have to build VaynerMedia,
you don't have to build Bain and McKinsey,
be you, and be your best
self your way, and enjoy it.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Rayson] Would you mind,
would you help me video this?
Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Rayson] I am doing
great, my name is Rayson,
and I'm actually a
psychiatric nurse in practice,
and also a founder of
this brand called Raygacy,
because Raygacy means Rayson's legacy, so,
I wanna create my own legacy.
So, now that, now that
I'm actually in doing
freelance coaching,
training, and speaking,
motivational speaking, I
would like to actually ask you
if you and me, within the
next two to three years,
because I plan to leave nursing,
because I find that I
have a lot of potential,
and I believe I can do even more,
not just helping the mentally ill,
and even my mother, who
suffers from schizophrenia,
I want to help people around
and impact lives, as well,
inspire them, what would you suggest,
or what would you do if
you were in my position?
- And you wanna leave
in two or three years.
- [Rayson] Yes.
- I would save money.
- [Rayson] Save money.
- Save money.
And produce content to create
awareness for when you leave,
and I wouldn't spend money on dumb stuff,
because when you go make that jump,
you wanna be in the most safe
place financially, right?
So, I would save money
and produce content.
- [Rayson] I have been producing content,
which is what I call the Raygacy Show,
so the Raygacy Show is
actually where I interview
entrepreneurs, successful
entrepreneurs, actors even,
even just now I actually
interviewed a chef, as well,
and I interview a lot of people.
I already have done only
11 episodes for now,
but I am doing more,
because I'm actually using
Facebook Live to do it,
because I feel that Facebook
Live has always been
a negative component where
people actually use it
to see people jumping down, or accidents,
and stuff like that, so I
wanted to use it as a value,
adding content, so I use
it, and then after that,
I convert it to YouTube
and then I will share it
on YouTube and let people watch, as well.
So, yeah, so, this is
the thing that I'm doing,
and one thing is I want
to actually scale it up.
I want to have more people to watch it,
I want to have more viewers and.
- Well, there's two things you have to do.
Make more shows, and be more interesting.
Because, don't forget,
you're doing something
very interesting to me.
You said that you have the potential
to be very motivational,
that you wanna help people,
this, that, the other thing,
but then your first execution in media
is to trade off other people's equity.
It's an insight, there's
nothing wrong with it.
No different than the
last conversation we had.
There's nothing wrong with
anything if you have good intent,
but you have to be
thoughtful and ask yourself,
if you have so much potential
to be so motivational
and bring value, why
did you go down the path
of having guests, which is
always the quickest tell
to needing something else to drive content
versus just being on yourself and up here.
And it's important for you
to be honest with yourself.
Maybe you're trying to get
your legs underneath you,
there's nothing wrong with it,
but the way you framed it up,
where you converted your name into legacy,
and your first move is to
interview other people,
which is the real driver of it, you have,
the first thing I would say is do not jump
until you're ready at a place where you
can command an audience by yourself
without leveraging somebody else.
The reason I knew that I was gonna win
in business content in podcast,
was 99% of podcasts were people
interviewing other people,
which means the host is the commodity
and the guest is the draw.
There's so many subtleties in everything
that we're doing here.
You gotta look for them,
because they're really interesting tells
to what's really going on, right?
Like the last wonderful,
the lady next to you,
but I'm excited, to me,
that's gonna be the thing
I think about on the flight, I'm like,
I think she's gonna win.
You have to get to that
place where you realize
if you're the one making the rules
and nobody can hit it, that
needs to be thought about.
What does that mean?
Same for you, if you're
gonna make that jump,
especially when you have the audacity
to convert your name into legacy.
(audience laughing)
That you need to be good
enough before you jump
into not being at the
mercy of somebody else.
- [Grayson] Okay, okay, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Grayson] Do you mind if
I have a photo with you?
- Sure.
- Thank you.
- Last one?
- [Man] Gary, I would just wanna get
as close as possible because
I still can't believe
I'm talking to you.
- Thank you.
- [Man] Okay, and this is
the last question, guys.
- Sure, I got you.
- [Man] Gary, you talk a
lot about self-awareness.
- Also, if you're gonna go for legacy,
you're gonna have to
learn how to take selfies.
Just kidding.
Awesome, thank you, my
friend, good luck to you.
Yes, sir.
- [Man] Gary, among all the
things that you talk about,
being branding, marketing,
and all of that,
the thing which hits me hard
the most is self-awareness,
because you always talk
about self-awareness,
and the reason why that's so is because
I've got a brother who was
born with cerebral palsy.
He was born with cerebral
palsy, he was a breech baby,
and doctors said that he wouldn't be able
to live for more than 24 hours.
But then, he's gone on, he's
achieved some good things,
he's even written a book that's
titled Better Than Normal,
it's the t-shirt that I'm wearing,
and he wants to become a speaker,
he wants to go on and inspire life,
our big mission to, our dream
is to inspire 50 million
people by 2050, and
coming to the question,
do you think, because
you are super successful,
you're a super successful entrepreneur,
everything that you are,
we all wanna be you,
I wanna be you.
Do you think you would
have been this successful
if you were born with
some kind of disability,
or if you were born, I know
you had some disadvantages
in your life, but do you
think you would have been
this successful if you were
born with a disability,
something that you cannot
change about yourself,
something physical.
- I don't know.
I don't know.
I think it would be crazy for
me to answer that question.
Here's what I would say.
I think that disadvantages
are the ultimate advantage.
I think adversity is a
humongous advantage in life,
but when you go into real diseases or
things that could create
huge insecurities,
if you're born without an eye, as a child,
having a glass eye could
have created such a complex
that maybe the confidence
would have never been there.
So, I think it's crazy for
me to even take a stab at
judging what would have been.
I think that would be inappropriate.
- [Man] And the reason why I say that,
because although our brand
is Better Than Normal,
if you ask Hitesh, he's
not here today because
he's in India doing his
therapy and we are doing
a movement in India because
the market is bigger,
but he's gotta do
therapy every single day,
six to eight hours of
it just to maintain his,
just to maintain his state,
and if you ask Hitesh,
even though we want to
inspire 50 million by 2050
to become better than
normal, if you ask him,
Hitesh, before you die, what
is the one thing that you want,
the irony of it is that he will tell you
that he wants to be normal.
- Of course.
Because that's his truth.
You know, instead of some
arbitrary number of 50,
I mean, 50 million people in 2050
is an arbitrary thing
that you guys stumbled on
that has zero anything.
I think the, to me, I've
always thought about it as.
(clicking)
Best way to get to 50 million
is to focus at one at a time.
The second I hear 2050,
50, I'm like, finished.
Finished.
Right, like, so, that makes sense,
and I think it's super
awesome to see the love
you have for your brother,
I think, couple things.
You need to do me one favor.
A, have no interest in being me,
B, have no interest in
wrapping yourself up
in your brother's story,
because you're just
gonna end up resentful,
and you need to,
ironically, you started
with self-awareness,
you need to go inside yourself and really
figure out what you're doing here.
How much are you using
this for your own want,
how much are you doing this
for him, you need to get,
the way you structured all this,
this could get real bad real fast.
And so, I want you to promise
me to just be thoughtful,
because a lot of times,
it's the same way I see,
like, I spend a lot of
time in this dynamic,
you need to be careful.
- [Man] My main purpose
in my life I feel is
I want him to be independent,
physically, emotionally, mentally,
that's what I really want,
regardless of the brand,
regardless of whether we make any money,
I want him to be independent.
- If that's your number one.
- That's my number one.
- Then that has nothing to do with the way
you're positioning everything
that you're talking about.
There's nothing you said that even comes
remotely to mapping to that truth.
- [Man] I want him to know that,
I don't think he knows that,
that that's my number one.
- So, go tell him.
- [Man] I told him that a million times,
but he somehow believes that
it's not my responsibility
for him to be independent.
- That would make sense.
You need to be thoughtful.
Promise me, because this
scenario turns out bad a lot.
You end up with nothing.
Not your brother, not
the brand, just be smart.
- [Man] And I know you
don't read a lot of books,
and you've probably read
only four books in your life,
but I would just like
to give this one to you,
maybe for your kids, maybe
some time when you have.
- Sure.
- Thank you so much, Gary.
- Welcome.
- Thank you very much, guys.
Thank you, Gary!
Put your hands together
for Gary Vaynerchuk,
ladies and gentlemen!
- Thank you.
Cool, cool, cool, as
Marcus Krzastek would say,
great character at VaynerMedia.
Anyway, nonetheless, hope
that went well for you,
and would love your comment below
of your favorite question
from the keynote,
not your favorite thing that I said
or the thing you learned,
but your favorite question,
and why, from this keynote, see you.
(intriguing music)